hey everyone and welcome to the full
cost on PHP programming by simply learn
in this video we'll discuss everything
you need to know about PHP
now before we begin make sure to
subscribe to Simply learn and do hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so let us see what we've got for you
first we'll start by a proper into PHP
followed by learning how to use Zam
software to build our first hello world
PHP program
then we'll learn all the basic PHP
programming Concepts right from
the very beginning to scenarios we will
then move on to learning after
programming in PH next we will have lhp
extensions that can be integrated into
Visual Studio code for a better
programming experience
we will also learn about PHP get and
post methods followed by a tutorial on
how to implement MySQL with PHP PHP form
validation credit operations in PHP
PHP registration and login form
we will also discuss rest apis in PHP
followed by an extensive web development
tutorial by creating a website
next we will also work on an e-commerce
website tutorial and finally we will
have a look at the most frequently Asked
PHP interview questions
so without any further Ado let's get
started
let us first meet Rob Rob is the owner
of an e-commerce business earlier his
customers were very happy with the
products they purchased from his website
but with more traffic and user base Rob
started receiving complaints from his
customers not related to the products
but the website itself
now the customers were facing challenges
like slow website speed bad user
experience and poor security features
like any other business owner Rob wanted
to rectify the problem but he was unable
to find solution to it
well developing his website in PHP can
solve all of Rob's problem and guess
what PHP is simple to learn and easier
to implement
let me elaborate on this the PHP is
useful in many ways as first and
foremost it can make the website
function faster
it can create Dynamic web pages and
dynamic web pages are what makes a
website more Interactive
next it provides security encryption it
is a cost efficient language it is very
compatible as it works efficiently with
different databases and programming
languages and it is platform independent
which means a PHP application can run on
any environment
now before moving into the details did
you know that 79.2 percent whip is still
powered by PHP which nearly translates
to 20 million websites and 1 million web
servers
now in this presentation you'll learn
about what is PHP how does it work
differently from a conventional web page
what are its features some major
companies where PHP is implemented
prerequisites on learning it and finally
we will have a look at the demo for a
first PHP program
now without further Ado let's get
started
so what exactly is PHP PHP stands for
hypertext preprocessor which is a
recursive acronym it is an open source
server-side scripting language that is
embedded into HTML and use of web
development
now before we get overwhelmed by the
technical terms let me simplify them for
you now for those of you who don't know
open source is a term for technology
which means it is freely available to
everyone while server-side scripting
means that from writing the code to
implementing and processing it
everything is done on the server side
while the user just lays down and enjoys
the experience now that we know what PHP
is
let's see how PHP script looks like
as you can see on the screen this is the
syntax of PHP it opens with an angle
bracket question mark PHP and ends with
a question mark and an angle bracket
while the code comes in between them
now as you can notice this is very
similar to how HTML codes are written
now let's have a look at some features
of PHP
now while PHP being a very diverse and
featured language some of its main
features are listed here
let us try and understand them one by
one
first is simple
now this feature comes as a good news to
new Learners since PHP is simple and
hence an easy to learn language
next comes flexibility PHP is a highly
flexible language in conventional web
pages even the smallest of changes have
to go through the developer who changes
the code to implement them well PHP
gives you the flexibility to make small
changes without the intervention of the
developer itself
it is also platform independent which
means it does not require any special
plugins to run and can basically run on
any environment
next is interpreted PHP is an
interpreted language and does not
compile the entire code hence taking
less time
which takes us to our next feature that
is fast
websites developed in PHP are faster
this is why developing Dynamic websites
using PHP is considered as the best
option
as discussed earlier too PHP is called
as an open source language which means
it is free to use and implement
next feature is security
the language consists of a few built-in
Frameworks that provides benefits like
encryption and hence protection from
cyber attacks
next is a large PHP Community since PHP
is an old language it has grown up to a
large community which is very helpful
and makes the language more stable
so that was all about features of PHP
moving forward let us discuss the
workflow of a PHP webpage
how does a pH page work
so for a better understanding let us
first see how a basic HTML page
functions
in the basic HTML workflow when you open
a website on your browser a request is
sent from the browser to the server and
the server then Returns the requested
page stored on it back to the browser
now that's it
no matter what device or what purpose
you open the website for the page return
is always the same or you can say static
now what PHP does different is when you
open a website developed in PHP a
request in dot PHP extension is sent to
the server into the server there exists
a PHP interpreter which recognizes the
dot PHP file and interprets it based on
the request from the browser it pulls
out data from its database and file
systems and returns a HTML page
personalized according to the user
now let me give you an example to make
it more clear
when you log into your account on drops
new e-commerce website made on PHP it
takes your unique request to the server
and shows you products based on your
past preference and liking instead of
showing you the exact same page every
time now this makes the website Dynamic
and more interactive to the user
also guys before moving forward if
you're enjoying this video please give a
thumbs up and subscribe to Simply learn
for more such content
so that was all about the workflow of
PHP let us discuss the companies using
them
many companies have reached great
success by implementing PHP into their
websites let me list down a few of them
first comes Facebook the biggest social
media platform did you know that
Facebook was created entirely on PHP
and according to the website similar web
PHP is visited by users for nearly 22
billion times per month this means the
social media platform has to deal with
huge traffic volumes and PHP helps a
website with this
now before moving to the next website a
quick question for you guys what is the
one site everyone goes to for
information
correct it's Wikipedia and guess what it
is written in php2
now platforms like WordPress which are
used to create beautiful websites itself
are also based on PhD
and blogging and social media channels
such as Tumblr and even multi-service
platforms like Yahoo which face huge
amounts of data traffic every day uses
PHP to function
so now that I hope you're more motivated
to learn PHP let us look at some of the
prerequisites of learning it
now since PHP scripts has already
discussed are embedded into HTML codes a
basic understanding of HTML comes
naturally as a prerequisite
again a website cannot be complete
without the implementation of CSS hence
a basic understanding of CSS is also a
must
next is basic knowledge of programming
language now this is not necessarily a
prerequisite but if you have basic
knowledge of programming fundamentals
such as oops concept functions and
arrays Etc it would really help you
along the way let's get started and
learn what exactly is xampp now Zam
stands for cross-platform Apache server
Mario database PHP and then finally Perl
Zam is an open source application that
is developed by Apache friends and is
one of the easiest ways to host a local
web server with access to mySQL database
PHP and Perl
so it is an all-in-one package so now
that we have an understanding of what
zamp is let us set up the software on
our system and then see how to use it to
run a PHP script
so now to set up the Zam software what
we need to do is let us open the browser
and download
our software
so as you can see here
apachefriends.org is the official
website from where you can download the
Sam software
since we are using the windows version
we'll download it for Windows although
it is available for Linux and Mac OS as
well
now let's wait for the download to get
finished
it almost is
now
let's open the setup and install a
software right away
continue installation
next
now from here you can select all the
extra files that you want to install
along with the exam setup or you don't
want to install
now this is the default folder for xamp
installation that is C drive Sam and I
would recommend you keep it that way
I think there's some issue here
yeah well
this is the folder for my old xampp
now we wait for the installation to get
finished and then we'll run a quick PHP
script a welcome or hello world kind of
script to see how this Zam software
functions along with PHP
now the installation is almost done
we'll just wait for a few
now the installation is complete and
now let us open the control panel to
check if it's done correctly
yes
everything seems fine now so this is the
control panel for the Zam software which
includes all the services provided by it
and in our PHP tutorials we'll be mainly
using the Apache server and the MySQL
one so you need to click on Apache
server
started and MySQL now Apache server will
show you the default port on which it is
running now to check if xamp is
correctly installed on your system let's
open the browser again
and type localhost
now this will open up the dashboard for
the Zam application
let's click on PHP my admin
and the information is available here so
the installation is complete
similarly we'll install the visual
studio code since I've already installed
the software on my system I'll not be
doing that now let us come to the
important part
let us redirect to
C drive
and there we have our zamp installed
open the Zam folder and locate HD docs
now this is the folder where all your
PHP files codes and website related data
will be stored
now we'll open the HD docs and let us
create a new folder here
since it will be a first program let us
name it
first
PHP
now let's open our code editor that is
Visual Studio code
click on open folder
locate to Zam
HD dots and the folder we created first
PHP
as you can see let me close this first
as you can see first PHP folder is
visible here let us create our first PHP
file
let's name it
Hello dot PHP now don't forget the dot
PHP extension otherwise the code will
not run now since a browser only
understands HTML code we will have to
embed the PHP script into the HTML code
itself so let's begin let me Zoom it a
little bit so you can see clearly
let me
add a heading so H1 will be too big
let's keep it to H2
my
first
PHP
web page
let's write our first PHP script so a
PHP script begins with an opening
angular bracket question mark PHP
now we'll write the PHP script that is
Echo
hello world now Echo acts as a print
function which prints any string that is
in front of it in this case it will
display hello world onto the web page
let's close the script with a question
mark and a closing angular bracket and
also close our HTML code
now before running a web page let us
first check if the web server is still
active
yes the web server is still running
so let's open the browser
type localhost now type the name of the
folder that you've created that is first
PHP
now as you can see our hello.php file is
presented let's click on it
and as you can see our first web page is
visible
which shows the heading my first PHP web
page and the hello world from a PHP
script in this video on PHP programming
we're going to discuss different PHP
Concepts from the very Basics such as
syntax hello world program up until
learning how to collect form data using
PHP scripts and also cover a lot more
Concepts in between now what we need to
do is to use Visual Studio code
what we do is we go to C drive Zam
folder or wherever you have installed
your Zam software we go to that folder
locate htdocs and let us now create
another folder and you can name it
anything that you want to based on your
project since we are discussing the
concepts let us name it Concepts
now right click on it and
here as you can see it shows open with
code
when you click on it
you can see that it opens Visual Studio
code for you
along with the concepts folder that we
just created now this is where you will
create all your files for your project
and will be writing all of your PHP
Scripts
now let's create the first PHP file from
here new file
let us name a tutorial dot PHP
and see how a PHP syntax looks like
so a PHP syntax begins with an angular
opening bracket question mark PHP and
ends with a question mark and a closing
angular bracket while the PHP script
goes in between
so this is the very basic syntax of how
PHP scripts are written
now let us move on and see how to write
a hello world program using a PHP script
so
you print something on PHP
Echo is used
now to use Echo what you need to do is
just write the string that you want to
print in front of it and save the
program so hello
and
welcome to
Sim relearn
let us close it and save the file now I
am going to show you how to use the Sam
software in order to run PHP Scripts
go
and open your Zam control panel
and from the control panel you have to
start this first service that is Apache
now this is going to start a local web
server on your system
now open your browser
go to a new tab and type localhost
followed by the name of the folder that
we just created into htdocs that was
Concepts
and hit enter
here you can see the file that we just
created tutorial.php and when you click
on it you can see your first program
visible here hello and welcome to Simply
learn
now suppose you have a program that
needs to print this exact same string
again and again throughout the program
so what are you going to do type the
entire Echo statement through your code
or make it simpler now to make it
simpler what we need to do is we need to
go back to our code
and discuss the concept of
variables
Now to create a variable
what we need to do is we need to
use this dollar sign
followed by the name of the variable you
can name it anything you want so let us
name it SDR
and type
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
so this is a first variable now this
variable Str stores this string value
also you can create different variables
for different purposes such as if you
want to store a number suppose so
you can store number five and suppose
you want to store a floating variable
and that would be float
and a floating variable is a number of
decimal points so 7.6
so now we have three variables in our
program
now one thing to notice if you're coming
from a different programming language is
that you don't need to define the type
of variable in PHP that is if it is a
string number or a floating variable
now to print this
we can use Echo but when you want to
print a variable in Echo you need to do
things a little differently so
let us start with H1 heading
now to print a variable what you need to
do is you need to use Dot
followed by the name of the variable
that would be Str
and another Dot
followed by if you want to type
something
along with the variable
I am going to copy this code
and paste it
now
let us change the size of the headings
and also change a variable so in the
second line we are going to print num
and in the third
the float that we created
so now we have all of our variables into
our Echo now let us save this program
and see
what it does
so as you can see
the variables are printed on your
program and you don't have to write them
again and again you can simply write
name of the variable along with Echo and
Dot and print it along
now that we know about variables suppose
we want to print the names of different
laptop Brands available in the market
now what you're going to do do you
create different variables for each name
that is a variable for HPA variable for
Lenovo variable for a source or do you
want a single variable to store store
all of the names of the laptop Brands
available
now with arrays it is possible to store
different information of the same data
type that is integer string
under a single variable
the condition is all of the data that is
stored under the variable should have
the same data type
now let us see how array works
now array stores multiple values in a
single variable as we already discuss
now to make an array first what we need
to do is
name a variable laptop
brand
and
type in Array function
and under that function
we are going to write the names of
different laptop brands that is HP
with separated by commas Lenovo
Asus
and
Del
so
suppose these are the four laptop brands
that are available in the market in your
area
now
what you need to do is you need to print
what is
in this particular variable that is
laptop brand
so to print it
you need to First create variable dump
now what variable dump does is
it as you can see here it
exports the variable that is in its
function now we are going to write the
variable that we just created into the
variable dump function and it will just
return the data type and value
now suppose you want to print it so to
print it what we need to do is just add
echo in front of it
okay now before moving on to seeing the
result of this program
let us just
make this part of the code
inactive now to do that we are going to
learn A New Concept in between that is
comments
so comments are the lines in a code that
are not executed while the program is
run so
a single line comment starts with do
slash and anything written in front of
it is does not run along with the code
so these comments are very useful when
you're writing a code
to make your code readable and more
understandable by any coder who will
or might later on use the code that
you've just created now suppose what we
can do with comments is
I'm going to write a comment just in
front of it
this is a
string
variable
now
after this
slashes
anything written is not executed when I
am going to run the program
also now
what do you do if you want to
make this whole part of the code not
functioning
do you add
two slashes in front of everything
or you can use a much simpler method
that is multi multi-line comments to use
multi-line comments what you're going to
do is
your slash star this marks the start of
the multi-line code and
to end this use star and slash again and
everything in between does not run when
you're going to run your program
so
we will now see how this
array works
we will just
reload this page and as you can see
HP Lenovo Asus and Dell are visible here
also you might notice this array 4 shows
the length of the error
and this shows the position where all of
these strings are inside the array that
is an array starts with the zero
position not one but zero so the first
would be zero position that is HP
and then one Lenovo and subsequently
Asus and that
now suppose you just want to print the
second variable in your array what you
need to do is you need to go back to
your code
and in front of the variable you need to
write the position that you want to
print
under square brackets that is the second
position in Array would be number one
and save the code
go back to the browser
and only the second
array is the second
variable in the array is visible
now suppose instead of a variable we
want to create a value that you don't
want to be changed throughout your
entire program
so consonants are used for the same
purpose now consonants are very much
like variables except that once they are
defined they cannot be changed or
undefined so
let us see how consonants work
first
we will
put this code
under a comment
and now start writing a consonant
so to define or create a consonant what
you need to do is use the Define
function
and inside the Define function what you
need to do is you need to write the name
of the consonant
and
okay first let us write the name of the
consonant suppose
laptops
followed by the value
of the
HP
consonant Lenovo
and Asus
and that's it and you close the defined
function and there you have defined your
consonant in your PHP script now this
cannot be changed or undefined
throughout your program
now to print it what you need to do is
type Echo followed by the name of the
consonant that you've just created so
the name of the consonant is laptops
save the code go back
and HP Lenovo and Asus
are visible here
you can also create consonant arrays
along with a normal consonant Now to
create a consonant array you just need
to add a square bracket
just a second
let me close this one
separated by
commas
and now we have
the names of the laptop as an array
which by the way cannot be changed or
undefined through your throughout your
code just like any other consonant now
suppose you want to just print the name
of the third laptop that is available in
the market
now what you need to do is you need to
write the position and the third
position in case of arrays would be
number two
save
and only Asus is visible here
so this is how consonants and variables
work in PHP
now before moving on to the next section
let me give you another situation
now suppose I want you to print
a number only and only if it is greater
than 7. how do you do that
now since it is a condition conditional
statements are used to perform different
actions based on different conditions
now some of the conditional statements
include in PHP are if if else if else if
else and switch and we're going to
discuss them one by one
no so the first one is if
now let me create a variable let us name
it there and
write the value 8.
now the example that we just discussed
if we want to check
if this variable is greater than 7 and
only and only then print the variable on
a screen
now to do that what we need to do is
type in if
and in the bracket we need to type the
condition that we're going to check that
is if
variable
greater than 7
now use curly brackets and inside the
curly bracket write the code that you
want to execute only and only if the
condition in of this if is met
so we need to print this variable
so Echo
where
and go and save it now go back
and reload and you can see it is printed
here
now let us go back and change the value
of the variable to 5.
and save it go back reload
and as you can see nothing is printed on
the screen since the condition that we
just mentioned inside if does not meet
now suppose
I tell you that
if the condition does not meet you have
to print
a string saying that the condition does
not did not meet
how do you do that to do it what you
need to add after if is
else
and else does not need to have a
condition since as the English word
suggests it is else
which means the condition of if did not
meet and inside the else we are going to
write the code
Echo
the condition
did not meet
save it
the condition did not meet
foreign
for another condition now suppose I want
I ask you to check if a number is
divisible by 2 3 or both
how do you do that
now to do that first
let us create a number six
now check if
variable
percent
to
is equals equals to zero now what this
shows is this
brings out the remainder and if the
remainder is 0 that means it is
divisible by 2.
and we need to add one more condition
here
and and
variable
percent three
equals equals to zero and what this does
is it checks if both of these conditions
are true that is
if the number inside the variable is
divisible by both 2 and 3.
we will display
divisible by both
now
what we need to do is we need to
checked if it is divisible by 2. so
else if
so since it is else if we need to add a
condition in it too else if
variable
person 2 equals equals to zero
Echo
Divas
built by 2.
similarly
divisible by
three
another you can add as many else if
statements as you want
and the final else will show
okay
let us go back and save a program
since a variable is 6 it should show
divisible by both
and you can see it shows exactly the
same divisible by both now let us change
the value and see if our program works
so what we are going to do is we are
going to change the value to 4
save our program
and run it again
this by two
similarly
nine
divided by 3 and finally 13
not divided by either 2 or 3.
so this is how you can make use of if
else if and else statements
now the next conditional statement is
switch statement now the switch
statement is used to perform different
actions based on different conditions
so let me again give you a situation so
that you understand better
so suppose you're playing a game
which has four different levels and
first level is easy medium hard and
extreme so
you need to print that
now what will you do you can also use if
else if but it's a lot of code
search statement makes it a lot lot
simpler and more readable so what we
need to do is we need to
type in switch
okay first what we need to do is first
we need to create a variable
so a variable suppose
let us name it level
and
11 is 3.
to create a switch statement you need to
type in switch and
enter the name of the variable that will
be passed into the switch statement to
check for the conditions
level
and it also begins with a curly bracket
and inside
the search statement what you need to do
is you need to type case
that is
the first case would be case
1.
followed by a colon
and the statement that you want to
execute that is
Echo
you
are
playing Act
easy level
and since you want your program to stop
Health cell what you need to do is you
need to type in break
similarly for rest of the levels I'll
just copy this code here
2 3 and 4. and just make the changes
and similar to if else statements you
also need to add another statement that
would be
default if any of the conditions are not
met in the switch statement suppose the
value of your variable is 20 which does
not make any sense to the game then what
you need to do is
you need to display a default error
message and that would be
invalid
input
and you also need to
end the switch statement
with
a curly braces
and and the
PHP program
all right let us save it
go to a browser
and run you are playing at hard level
I guess you must have understood the
concept let us just one more time
change the value of the variable to 20
save it go back
invalid input
so this is how the conditional
statements in PHP work
next what we're going to talk about is
PHP loops
now suppose you want to run a block of
code or a part of code again and again
and again or in other words in Loop
so PHP has that functionality known as
PHP loops to do the same task
now there are different types of PHP
Loops available that is while do while
and for Loops which we will be
discussing in this part of the video
now let us start with the while loop now
the while loop
Loops through a block of code as long as
the condition that you have entered or
specified in the while loop is true
so
let me just
remove it
now to write a while loop what you need
to do is type while followed by the
condition
and to write the condition what we need
to First do is let us create a variable
and
will give it a value of 2.
now the condition which we are going to
write is this is just an example so if
for while the value of variable
is
less than equals to
10.
and then we follow along with the curly
braces
and type the code that we want to run
again and again until the value of a
variable becomes 10
or till the value of a variable is less
than 10.
suppose
number
and then the variable that is
where
and that's about it
now what we need to do is we need to
increase the value of the variable else
this code this code will run for an
infinite amount of time and the system
might crash so
to increase the variable in each
iteration what we need to do is we need
to use the plus plus operator
which will increase the value of the
variable by 1 in each iteration
are we going to save the code
and run it number two three four five
six seven and so on
let me just
add
break here and you can see all of the
numbers up until 10 are visible here and
after 10 the loop just stops
so let me explain it again so what we
are doing is we are writing while
along with the condition until
then the code is supposed to be run
again and again so the condition is if
the value of the variable is less than
or equals to 10 since a value of
value of R variable is 2 the condition
is true so the code inside of this vial
is executed and the code will display
the value of the number
and
variable value will increase with each
iteration until it becomes greater than
10 and then the loop will exit
now the do while loop is very very
similar to the while one the only
difference being in case of a do while
loop a
code this this code will execute at
least once
I'll show you how it works so
in case of do while
we start with two curly braces
let us use this same example
and after the curly braces what we do is
we write while along with the condition
that is
equals to 10.
let me just
okay
now let me tell you what do we need do
value suppose
the value of a variable
is
11. now since the condition did does not
meet in case of the while loop it will
not even run once now suppose you want
to display the current value of the
variables whether or not if it meets the
condition at least once
so in case of do while
it will first go into this do Loop
run the code and then after the do Loop
is complete this part of the code is
complete it will go on to the while part
and check the condition now if the
condition does not meet the loop will
end here and if it meets it will
continue until the condition does not
meet the while part
so it will run at least once now
save this and go back to a browser
and reload this program and as you can
see in number 11 is visible here
so do while is helpful in some cases
which you'll realize as low as you start
coding more and more
now next up is follow now for Loop is
used when we already know how many times
you want the loop to run so for Loop is
used when you want to run a piece of
code a specific number of times
now let me show you how it works
now the for Loop is written in three
parts here we don't need to Define a
variable beforehand the first part of
the for Loop is defining the value of
the variable so
variable is equals to let us
valued at 1.
now we want to make it run till suppose
six values
so what we need to do is
we need to
write the condition
in the second part of the for Loop if
variable less than equals to 6
and in the third part will be the
incremental part so as you can notice in
while and do while we put the
incremental part inside the block of the
code here the incremental part is inside
the for function itself
variable plus plus
and then we start with the curly basis
and we write the
code similar to
I'll just
copy it from here
and now let us
just save it and print to show you
how it works
number one two three four five and six
now these Loops are a very important
aspect of programming and you all should
try out different problems based on
Loops by yourself
now next up in PHP is PHP functions
now functions are a very very useful and
very important part of programming in
any language
or functions are of two types
built-in functions and user defined
functions now built-in functions are the
functions that are already present
inside the framework of your programming
language
a very popular example of a function
built in function of PHP is Echo Echo is
a function that is already built in PHP
and is used to print out variables
strings and values
on the screen now user defined functions
are functions you create yourself
to use a code
repeatedly in your program
so I'll explain you with while writing
the code itself so suppose you want to
use this for code
four or five times in your program
so or even more maybe 10 20 30 40 100
times a new program if you're writing a
very very large program you want to
print or use this part of the code 100
times in your program what do you do do
you write this entire code or copy paste
this entire code again and again 100
times and make your code
lendia or do you just want to use this
piece of code from here
from anywhere in your program
now to do that we need to put this piece
of code inside a user defined function
so how do we do that
we do that by writing
function
followed by suppose you want to call
this function a name
and start with curly braces
now this is a user defined function
named name
now inside this name function is a piece
of code
this
for
now how do we reuse it
I'll show you in a second
so
suppose you are a long way from your
code from dashboard you don't even know
where it is
you want to use this code again after
writing hundreds of lines of code so how
do you do it
you just type the name of the function
that is name
and close it that's about it this is
called calling a function so it is
similar to calling a friend for help so
here you just called your friend name
to execute this part of the code
here
save
and well there are no changes since the
output will be the same
let us make some changes
add another Echo
um
I'm going to run it again later
and
call this function again
save it
and as you can see once the function is
called the output is printed and I am
going to run it again later and then
again the function is called and it
uses the same piece of code again and
again and again
see how simple coding can be when you
know what to use when
now let's move ahead and understand the
concepts of oops in PHP
so as you can see on the screen I have
listed down the eight concepts of oops
that we will be discussing today
first is class next comes objects then
it's member functions and member
variables that Constructor and
Destructor
inheritance and finally it is
polymorphism
now let's walk through each of the
concepts one by one
first is class
it is a blueprint of an object that
provides initial values for the state
a class consists of both data and
functions and data and functions
together are called objects
now let's first have a look at the class
let me create a file
named class dot PHP
and let us write the code first
all right
foreign
a class by using the class keyword
followed by fruit which is the class
name
next I have added a pair of curly braces
and added the entire properties and
methods within the braces so as you can
see on the screen we have declared a
class named fruit that contains two
properties called name and color
along with that I have also added two
methods set name and get name
now now the purpose of these methods is
for setting and getting the name
property
so let me give you some in important
information so when you define a class a
variable in it is called property while
a function is known as method
now let us execute the code and see the
output
let's go to the browser
and type localhost slash followed by the
file name
here's a file class dot PHP and as you
can see on the screen the code is
running perfectly
now that was about the class
next comes objects so it is an instance
of a class basically a variable holds a
data of a class
now we define a class once
and create as many objects in it
it's for a better understanding let me
give you an example suppose a car is a
class so Mercedes-Benz and BMW would be
objects
now let's see objects classes are
incomplete without objects so we can add
as many objects as we want from a class
and every single object has the
properties and methods defined in the
class but those objects will have
different property values
so objects of a class are created using
the new keyword
now let me open the code editor
and let's create another file called obj
dot PHP
so this code will be the same let's copy
and paste it here
now let me type the code for object
[Music]
as you can see I have used the new
keyword to create object of the class
fruit
similarly
banana
would be another object
and now we'll use the set name function
to set the name to Apple on this object
on the Apple object that we have created
similarly we will
set the name
for the banana object
okay
there's an extra bracket here let's move
it
now moving forward let us type the code
to display
what we have added into the objects
for this can you guess which method
we'll be using
yes the get name method will be used to
display the name saved onto the object
using the set name method
now that our code is complete
let us run and check
if it's working correctly
let me go back
and refresh
now here we have our object.php file
yes the code runs perfectly the fruit
program and it is displaying apple and
banana from the two objects that we
created
I hope now you have clearly understood
the concept moving on to the next one
let's talk about the member variable and
member function
a member variable is defined within a
class
the data can be accessed by the member
functions alone now once the object is
built these variables are called
attributes of the object whereas member
function is defined within a class and
is used to access object data so next
comes Constructor
so it allows an individual to allot an
object's properties while the object
creation while a Destructor is a
function that is called when the object
stops working we will have a look at the
Constructor program
so Constructor allows an individual to
allot an object's properties while the
object creation
now suppose you build a program using
Constructor function
PHP will automatically call the
construct function while creating an
object from a class also remember that
when you write the construct function
always prefix it with two underscores
now let's have a look at the example
where we will be using a Constructor
function with calling the set name
method now this set name function is
often used when you assign a value to
the name attribute
now let's open the code editor and
create a Constructor file
will again create the two properties
named
name
and color
now we will create a Constructor with
two underscores and a construct keyword
and I'll give the two properties as the
attributes to the Constructor
now in this program we'll be using the
Constructor function
as the set method
to set the names
and color of a fruit by default
during the object creation itself
we still need to create the get
functions
now let's create an object to invoke the
Constructor
now since the Constructor has attributes
we will have to give the values for the
attributes as well
so the fruit would be
strawberry
and the color would be pink
so this creates a new object and it
gives
the values to the Constructor
in the PHP script
and
our HTML code as well
let us save the code and check if it's
working
let's go back
refresh now a Constructor file is
visible let's click on it and yes so
when the object strawberry is created
the attributes we have given to the
Constructor strawberry and the color
pink were already assigned to it
and it is displayed in the browser
itself
now that the Constructor program is done
next let's see an example of how a
Destructor works
let's open the code editor
create another file Destructor dot PHP
now the destructor code will be very
similar to The Constructor one so we
will copy the code into the destructor
file and make some changes
so let us remove this we don't need it
and write a Destructor function
so destructive function is written
similarly how Constructor function is
written so it starts with two
underscores and a district keyword
it does not have an attribute
now why did we delete the get functions
is because we will be using the
destructor
for it
okay
also we won't be needing this
does the object creation is sufficient
now let's save our program and
do the drill again
open the browser
a Destructor file is visible
and it shows the fruit is strawberry and
the color is pink so when the object
function is complete
and the program ends the destructor
function is called which displays the
strawberry and the color pink
now it comes inheritance so it derives
new classes or chat classes from the
parent class
however inheritance can have its own
properties and methods too
so inheritance has two classes first is
parent class and the other one is a
child class
now let's talk about each of them in
detail
so parent class is otherwise called a
base class that is inherited from
another class
and a child class is a subclass that
inherits from another class
a child class can have subclasses and
derived classes now let's have a look at
the inheritance program
so the child class is derived from all
the properties and methods from the
subclass in addition it can have its own
properties and methods too
so an inherited class is defined by
using the extents keyword
let's look at an example
open the code editor so I've taken the
Liberty to create the inheritance.php
file
and write some of the code that we have
already written so I'll be writing only
the code that is necessary for the
inheritance part
now also remember when you derive a
child class from a parent class only the
public methods are derived into the
child class so we will be creating the
methods as public in order them to be
inherited
okay
meet this function public
let's end this class
and create another class in order
to inherit this class
so we'll name another class as
cherry
extends
fruit
and we'll create another function for
Cherry so this function is exclusive to
Cherry
so we have given a message through this
method
now
let's create an object
cherry
new
and
give the values for the attributes of
this Constructor
foreign
let's save the code
and check if it's working
well there seems to be an error
now let's try to resolve it
okay got it so we
created the object
within the Cherry glass so it got
localized
what we need to do is put that code
outside of the Cherry class
and it should work fine now
yes so is Cherry a fruit or a berry
a cherry is a fruit and the color of the
fruit is red
and now we will talk about the last
concept that is polymorphism so
polymorphism has many forms the same
function is utilized for different
purposes
it has a class with a variety of
functions simultaneously sharing a
common interface
so inherited methods are overridden by
redefining the methods in the derived
class
now let me write the code to make it
clear
so I've already created the polymorphism
PHP file
I have copied The Inheritance code
into the polymorphism part
and then now we'll make the changes into
the derived class that is Cherry
so let's create a property named
width
now to override the Constructor and the
intro function
from the fruit class we will have to
create the same functions in the derived
class also
okay
now this function construct has got one
extra attribute in comparison to this
function construct
let's create the intro function to
foreign
let us create another object
to invoke
the functions
foreign
did you notice what we did here so when
we created the object Cherry for for the
Cherry class we gave three attribute
values instead of two
in order to invoke this construct
function
not this
let us run it and check
so it runs perfectly it displays the
fruit the color and the weight
in this video we will discuss some PHP
extensions that can be and should be
added in Visual Studio code to make PHP
programming a little easier and a life
solitary sampler
now to check the extensions available or
search any of them we need to go to this
tab that is the extensions tab
now these are the already installed
extensions on our system
and from here you can search
extensions available in the visual
studio code Marketplace
now the first extension and a must-have
extension is
PHP intellifents
now to understand what it does let me go
back to the Explorer
and open a test.php
so what I'm going to do is
write some basic PHP built-in functions
let us say
PHP
info
yeah
so
what you need to notice is when you type
PHP info
it shows a suggestion it is from the
built-in feature that is already
installed into the visual studio code
but when you click on this
that's it
now I'll show you the difference
go back to extensions
and install PHP intellects
now go back to your test file and again
type PHP
info now as you can notice you can see
two PHP infos here now when you click on
this one you can see all the details
about this function available
right here so this is what PHP Intel
fence is it intelligently
suggests an autofills parts of your code
to make your programming simpler and
much easier
now moving on to a second extension a
second extension will be PHP
mesh detector
now what PHP mesh detector does is it
analyzes your PHP code on every save
now there's no additional setup required
if PHP is already installed on your
system which already is
so
to see what it does let us install it
now before that let us go back to test
Dot
PHP
and let me just
open this now here you can see the
output of your code so if you go back to
PHP mesh detector install it
and go back to your code you can see PHP
mesh detector is visible here and after
everything that you write
it analyzes your code after every save
and it is pretty useful while writing
big and complex PHP codes
now let's move on to the next extension
which would be
PHP Auto
close tag now what PHP Auto close tag as
the name suggests does is when you open
a tab when you whenever you write a tag
that is suppose HTML
or body etc etc anything that you write
it will automatically close the tag and
you can simply start writing the code so
this extension has saved me a lot of
time finding what problem is in my code
fixing the bug when actually it was just
that I did not close the tag
so
suppose I write HTML and as you can see
it automatically closes the tag and you
can simply start writing the code
now moving on to our next step that
would be
PHP fmt that is PHP for matter
now
what it does is it formats your code
with proper indentation and
well your code looks much more readable
after this so let me just show you I
have already created a test2.php
let me just close this so as you can see
this code is not indented at all and
one might have trouble understanding
what is going on and what part of code
is under what loops and statements so we
go back to our extension PHP formatter
install it
go back to test one
sorry test two now
when you right click after installing
this extension you can see format
document section available then when you
click on it
the code gets automatically
indented and looks much more readable
now so as you may notice all these codes
Under comes under the if conditions
and
that's the rest of the code looks much
more readable now
now the last extension that I am going
to discuss is
PHP debug
now this extension you may not use it on
a very regular basis but this extension
is very helpful when you want to debug
your code and see what's wrong with it
all the instructions on how to use this
extension are written alongside it and
how to install how to use how to install
extra softwares in order to completely
utilize its potential
since this extension is a double adapter
between Visual Studio code and X debug
website that was developed by Derrick
returns
so
I'm going to install it
and this is the very website X debug
where any of your code is debugged
so these are some of the extensions that
you need to begin or ease your journey
into PHP
there are a lot more extensions
available for PHP and you can explore
more into them as you move forward we
will look at PHP in get and post
so all of us know that PHP is a
scripting language for creating web
pages but what is get in post
there are two ways the browser client
can send information to the web server
the get method and the post method let's
understand get method in detail first
the get method sends the encoded user
information appended to the page request
the page and the encoded information are
separated by the question mark character
now let's know more about the get method
the git method produces a long string
that appears in your server logs in the
browser's location box
it is restricted to send up to 1024
characters only
also never use the get method if you
have a password or other sensitive
information to be sent to the server
since it will show in the browser's
location box
next the get can't be used to send
binary data like images or Word
documents to the server
also the data sent by get method can be
accessed using the query string
environment variable
now let us try writing a code to
understand the get method better
so as you can see we have got the output
but if you look at the link
it has an ampersand symbol along with
the username and age we entered now
before the browser sends the information
it encodes it using a scheme called URL
encoding in this scheme name value pairs
are joined with equal sign and different
pairs are separated by the ampersand
also as we discussed earlier the page
request
and the encoded information is separated
by a question mark sign
so that was all about the get method
moving on to the next one let's have a
look at the post method
now the post method transfers
information via HTTP headers the
information is encoded at described in
the get method and put into a header
called query string
the post method does not have any
restrictions on data size to be sent the
post method can be used to send asci as
well as binary data and the data sent by
post method goes through HTTP header so
security depends on HTTP protocol used
by using secure HTTP you can make sure
that your information is secure now
let's have a look at the code now
now you must be wondering if both the
methods give the same output so what is
the difference between them
well the major difference between post
and get method is that get method
carries request
parameters appended in url string as you
can see here the parameters are visible
in the URL
while post carries request parameters in
message body which makes it more secure
way of transferring data from client to
the destination as you can see there is
no information in the URL
now a lot of people have raised a
request to create a code on the request
method too so let me tell you the
request variable can be used to get the
result from form data sent with both the
get and post methods let us try out a
code for the request method too
as you can see we have got the output
today we will learn how to link mySQL
database to your HTML code with the help
of PHP now to do that we will build a
simple registration form whose data will
be uploaded to the mySQL database and in
this tutorial you will learn how to
create that database how to link it to
your web page and also how to delete the
tables or entries from the database
now before proceeding I am expecting
that you guys have some basic
understanding of HTML PHP and MySQL so
without further Ado let's get started
also guys for this tutorial we'll be
working on Zam and visual studio code
now let's get started
so first we'll open the C drive Zam
folder
htdocs and let us create our folder
let's name it tutorial
and open the visual studio code and
start writing the code for a
registration page
let's create a file and name it
index.php
oh
foreign
form
and close the head
now let's give some heading to a
registration page
now to make it a little more interesting
let us suppose the registration page is
for a blood donation Camp so we will
name our heading as the blood donation
camp and
close it
let's give some background color
to the page
now to give some background color we
need to first know the code for it let's
search for color codes
well I like the saffron one
let's copy the code
paste it here
right div
ing for the
page registration form
now as you can notice I wrote this
heading as H1 and this one has H2 since
this will be a little smaller from the
first one
let's close the div
and write a form now
in this action part
write connect.php and this is the file
which we'll be creating later in order
to connect our registration page to the
database
and method
as post
let's name it user so the first entry
would be name
input type
would be
text
and we have to give every entry a name
in order to use it in the PHP code to
connect to a database
let's give this name name
now what I did here is I put the
required keyword here which would make
it compulsory in to fill this
section of the form in order to continue
I'm giving these break lines to
not make the form
clumsy
email so
naturally this would be the label for
email
and let me skip ahead with this section
so I have written the code for the
different fields that we are going to
have in a registration page so the first
one was name second email
third would be the phone number and
fourth obviously the blood group of the
person registering
as you can notice I have given necessary
type
for different fields so for email I've
given the type as email
for blood group text and phone as text
in case someone wants to enter the
entire phone number with the country
code
so now let us create an input button
that would be submit
and
name
let us keep it submit
ID would be
submit
let's close our form
and close the web page too
now let's save it and check
if it's working correctly now let's open
the browser before that first we need to
open the Sam control panel and start our
Apache server and MySQL server
and now let us go to the localhost type
a folder name that is tutorial
and open the form
well there seems to be a problem the
other fields are not visible
let's open a code and see what did we do
wrong
yeah well there's a spelling mistake
here
and since I copy pasted the code
the mistake got copy pasted too
well let's save it again and check if
it's working correctly
yes perfect
now before moving on to creating our
connect.php file we first need to create
a database itself
so first we need to go to Zam control
panel and click on admin now this will
open the PHP my admin section
where we will go to new
and create a database
okay let us name our database as
test one
let us give it five fields and name it
uses
first field would be ID
and it would be Auto implemented
second we will name it as name
email
this will also be worker
third one would be phone
variable characters since people can
enter the plus sign
to enter the country codes
and finally we will have our blood group
and let's create a
table here
well as you can see this is a structure
of the table and the table is created
now when you click on browse
it will show you the data in this table
itself since we haven't entered any data
yet it is blank
now let's open up code editor and create
a file
connect dot PHP and
let's get started
now here we will have to enter the name
we gave to a submit button and that
would be submit
now we will create a variable to
create a connection and we'll be using
the mysqli
underscore
connect function to do that
here we will have to enter the name of
the server since we our server is the
locally hosted server so we will have to
type localhost
now the type of user that would be root
now the third part is for the password
since we don't have a password for a
database it would be blank
and the fourth would be the name of our
database that is test one
now we will also check if connection
is not complete
we will have to display an error
connection field
now in this if condition we will check
if the entries in the fields of the
registration form
are null or not
we will have to do the same for the
second
second one was sorry I did not enter the
yeah
email
a third entry
was
phone
and a fourth and final entry would be
the blood group
I think we're done here
[Music]
um
now we will have to create
variables
to pick data from the
registration fields in a registration
page
now this post will be picking data what
we'll be entering here
now here we will have to enter the name
we have given here so for the name field
we have given the name as name itself so
we'll be writing it here
let's
copy this code
and make the changes
this would be email
let us also name it email
this would be
phone
this would also be phone and last one
would be blood group foreign
as the name I've given because
naming everything differently would just
create conclusion in your code
now let us enter this details into our
database now insert into SQL command
now this would be
the table name users
name
[Music]
email
tone
and alert group
now we will have to
send the respective values that would be
the
variables that we just created so first
would be name
second would be email
on
and let's go
now that we have entered the
data into the database let's create a
query
connected
to the command
and give a message if it's successful or
not
foreign
successful
else
error
occurred
let us close our PHP script here
and save the code
and let's see if it's working
so let's go back to registration form
and give some
details to it so let us name Sam
mail.com
[Music]
12345678 and the blood group
can be O positive
well there's some error that we've
experienced on line four
okay let's see
yeah we did not close this
okay
let's save it and try again
another error on line 12
what do we have here now
okay so this is my SQL I not MySQL
save
resend the form and entry successful now
the entry is successful you need to go
to your database which I've shown to you
earlier
go to the table users
and we can see the details present here
Sam Sam at the rate mail.com the phone
number and the blood group
so now that we know how to create a
database link our database to our HTML
form and see the details into the
database entered
we can also delete these details from
this PHP my admin section itself so as
you can see to delete this field I just
have to click on this delete button OK
and the field is gone also if you want
to delete this users go to your database
click on users and click on drop
what it will do is it will drop the
entire table and if you want to delete
your database itself click on this
database
icon and click on drop the database
now this will remove the entire database
and all the tables associated with it
now let's enter one more detailed set of
details to double check it
let us give it Mac at the rate mail.com
that would be one two three four five
six seven eight nine
and the blood group would be a positive
and the entry successful
so to check it we need to go to a
database our table users
and there we have it math Mac at the
redmail.com and the rest of the details
today we are discussing everything about
cred operators in PHP
let's begin with the definition pose
crud stands for create read update and
delete these are the four fundamental
functions of persistent storage
these operators are used in creating
user interface conventions that help us
to view search and modify data via
computer-based forms and reports
basically the data is read built updated
and deleted
moving forward let me talk about the
purpose of this operations one by one
with the help of demo codes
but first things first let's create a
database
to do that
open Zam control panel and start Apache
and MySQL
now let's quickly open our web browser
open the localhost and go to PHP my
admin section
now let's
create a new database and name it
my DB
let's name the table users and we will
have
six fields in it
the first would be ID it would be
integer and auto incremented since it
would be the primary key
the second
would be
first name
type care let's give it 250
third would be
last name
variable character
similarly next would be an email
password
and finally
gender
so now that our table has been created
let's move on to the coding part now
first we are going to create a file
named config.php
to configure
the database
now we will create
variables
and I will explain the use to you later
now this is the
default username for a local host
Now the default password for a database
is empty since there is no password in
our database
and the database name
would be my DB that's what we have named
a database
now let's quickly create the connection
using
convariable
my sqli command
okay
server name
username
password
and the database name
now this will create a connection for a
database
and now let's
also
check for errors while creating the
database
okay
now if an error is found while
connecting to the database
it will show a message as connection
field
upload
now let's end the file
and move on to understanding the
different thread operations
now first comes create
so let us also create a new file and
name it create dot PHP
now the create procedure adds the insert
statement to create a new record now
let's write the code for this
now what this line will do is it will
as a link between the configuration
dot PHP file and this create.php to
connect to the database
now
we are checking
if the submit button on the form is
pressed
now when the submit button on the form
will be pressed the fields are required
to be sent to the database
for that we first need to create
different variables
similarly
last name
these are the names that we have given
to the
different sections in the table of our
database
password was password
and finally gender
foreign
query insert into the name of the table
that is users
and now
we need to name
the
fields we are going to be entering the
details into
since ID is auto implemented we are
going to be starting the first name
similarly last name
email
password
and
lastly gender
now
these are the fields we are going to be
entering data into now the values would
be
the variables that we just created which
are getting the data from the form using
the host function
into the variables
okay
so
first name
similarly
last name
email
password
gender
so the code to enter the values into the
database is complete
now let's also execute the query
to do that it will send the query using
the connect
all right
and put the attribute as SQL fields
now
if the records are created
it will display a successful message
else
in case of an error
it will show a error message
now let's
close the connection
to close function
and move on
to creating our HTML form
[Music]
now let's skip
aheading the distance this is a
registration page let's give the heading
a sign up form
create the form
let's leave the action field as blank
and method
would be since we're using post the
network would be post
[Music]
foreign
part now as you can see I've completed
the port for the registration form which
will include the first name
last name password
and gender
now let's
save it and move on to the next part
that is the view procedure now the view
procedure table records data based on
the primary key noted within the input
parameter
now let's create another file
named view dot PHP for it and write its
code
now I will run
and
displayed how these different operations
are working on the webpage
now let's write the query to get the
data from the user's table
users now this will
retrieve all the data into from the
table
also let us execute the query
using connect
query and pass
secure into it
and the PHP script
and right are HTML
code
title would be View
page
now I'm linking this page to uh
bootstrap CSS document
foreign
stylish
so it's basic HTML page looks pretty
boring
or to do that we are going to be using
the reference
when I have added the link for the CSS
file now let's
complete the rest of the page
okay
they're heading to this division
users
now this will also display the ID from a
table
so we are going to be creating a
different set of
column
to display the ID
similarly it will be the same
for the rest of fields so I'll just
copy this code this will be for email
gender
and editor
[Music]
gender
and action
let's close it
foreign
so this will check
there is data present in our database
now if there is data we are going to be
touching the same data
foreign
similar codes will be written for the
rest of the fields
so we will just let me
just copy and paste
and change the details
first name
last name
email
and gender
okay
foreign
yes
these are the chords for the edit and
delete commands
foreign
now let's quickly move on to the
third part update file
and write it
code
now when the update button for the form
is clicked
we need this code to process it
Okay so
and similarly
for the rest of the fields
let's click quickly change
user ID
should be ID
Le last name
last name
foreign
variables are complete now let's write
the query for the SQL
update
name of that
table
users
and set
first name
is equals to
and similarly
for the rest of the code
now
let's execute the query
pass SQL to it
again if
the record is a successful updation
pass successful message
and if any error has occurred
we will give an error message for it
tutorial
now if ID variable is set in the URL we
need we know that we need to edit a
record to do that
we will
again write a code
using get method
now we will write
SQL command to get the data
okay
and
execute our query
foreign
this is a very similar code to what we
have written earlier
to fetch the data if the number of rows
is greater than zero
foreign
[Music]
also skip ahead for the code
for this
update form
now this is the code for the update form
and now
last but not the least
we will
create the file or delete
and write a code
very similar to how we have written the
rest of the codes
foreign
let's write the SQL query the same old
routine so as you guess I'm going to be
skipping ahead with some of the part
some part of the chord
now this is the code for our delete.php
file
and now we will save all these files
and go to a browser and try to run check
if they run correct now let's
open the localhost first and go to
phpmyadmin
and opener
chooses field here
so as you can see I've already created a
record here I'll
create another one to show you how
for that let's go to localhost demo and
go to create.php
so second record let's name it Mac
X
simply learn
B
now the email would be Mac X at the rate
simply learn b.com
password
and submit new record created
successfully now let's refresh it and as
you can notice we have created another
record here
now
let's go
to localhost again
and
what was our next operation for crud it
was C create
our read that would be view.php now view
dot PHP displays both of the records
that we have saved
in our database now these number
differences would be because I have
created and deleted two more records
before recording this part of the video
now let's go to edit section of any of
this record
so as you may notice it opens the
update.php file
user update form
also the thing to notice is that it
refers
to the ID that we are updating in the
URL itself
now since we clicked on the edit part of
the first field it is updating the first
field itself
now let's update a miss
xxxx
there we see at the rate xyz.com
and update record updated successfully
now let's check the record
and yes the record is updated
now since we are done with the two parts
create read and even the third part
update Cru now let's move on to the D
that is delete
let's go to the delete
for that we would have to go to the view
dot PHP itself
now let us delete this
delete now you may notice the URL
delete.phpa ID code now ID equals 4 is
deleted from the database let's check
and yes the file from the database has
been deleted
so
this is how we perform arcade operations
with the help of PHP and mySQL database
today we are going to have a video
session on phpform validation
so what does this actually mean
okay well let me give you an example
here so when you try to create an
account on Facebook or Instagram you
submit a form and then that form is
cross-verified with the code written in
the backend
so today we are going to do the same
process in this video
now we will have a look at two demos now
in the first demo we will create a form
and in the second one we will validate
it so let's get started with the first
demo but first things first let's
quickly open
C drive Zam folder htdocs and
create a folder
let's name it validation
and open our code editor here
and let's create a first file
form dot PHP
now I am going to write the code for the
registration form
now here what we're doing is we are
creating the different variables for the
form and we are setting it to empty
values
let me put that in a comment too
foreign
will contain full name email number
comment gender and age now for this demo
the username email and mobile number
Fields will be text input elements while
the comment field will be a text area
let's write the next rest of the
now we are defining the test input
function which we are calling in the
above if statement
foreign
and add the method to post
action would be
let's see
so I skipped ahead and created all the
details required in the form so the
details would be full name its input
type would be text
uh it's just yet okay now
um second would be email similarly
number age comment now notice the
comment would be a text area instead of
a simple input type
gender
and a submit button
now the form is complete
we have to write another PHP script to
display the details
foreign
stuff
I'll just skip ahead in this part too so
now that we can display all of the
variables from the form let's close
the PHP script
and also close our
form
now let me explain some parts of the
code to you before we move on to the web
page part
so
here we have post
so this function is used at the time of
form submission now during that time the
form data is sent with method
equals to post
second would be the server section
now this server PHP itself is a global
variable that Returns the file name of
the code
now also HTML special characters
function convert special characters to
HTML entities now this prevents
attackers from exploiting The Code by
injecting HTML or JavaScript codes
that is cross-site referencing scripting
attacks in forms so now that we know
what these functions do let us jump and
see if our web page works okay
for that first open Zam control panel
and start the Apache server
and now let's open the browser and type
localhost followed by the folder name
that would be validation
and then a file name form.php
so yes the form looks good let's add
some name to it
email
xyz.com
number is optional but let's add some
number to it it would be 20 comment
would be
hello
welcome to
simply learn
gender would be male and let's click
here yes so our input is visible and the
form works perfectly
now let's move on ahead with our second
demo that is validating a form now we
will be writing a code but with slight
variations now the fields like full name
email address and websites will be added
here and these three Fields will show an
error if an incorrect input is given now
however the code is validated against
the input and returns an alert message
of an incorrect data is entered let's go
to the code editor and create another
file and let's name it
validate dot PHP
and write
another code for it
now I've added some color for the error
that will be shown into the form
again
let us write comment for it Define
variables
and
set to
empty
and a variables would be named err that
is error
similarly email error
gender trr
and the rest of the fields
foreign
or the field entered is correct
the name will be displayed as we
displayed the name in the form.php file
with the help of post
name
now what we are going to do is now we
will check if name only contains letters
and byte spaces
foreign
if the email address is well formed or
not
to do that we will again use an if
statement
I think I have used
IMI somewhere
since it's showing here em AI so let's
check before it throws an error in a
code
there's email yeah
okay we made a mistake here so this else
was not supposed to be closed here
let's move it ahead
yeah I think
this looks good
let's write
another code for
another variable
that is
website
and do the same thing again
the website
now we will check if the URL address
syntax is valid or not
so
let's just be a single
foreign
test input function as we did
in the form section so let's just
copy it from there since it's going to
be the same
now let's write the PHP script
for the form validation section
okay
foreign
[Music]
action would be
PHP script again
and just skip ahead with this part of
the program
so now that we have our complete form
here let's
close it
as you can see we have entered full name
email address website comments and
gender parts to the form now let's write
a final PHP script to display the
details
since this will also be similar to the
last part we will just copy it from the
and make the necessary changes
so
what we don't have is
full name this would be just name email
and this would be
a website
there's no number
delete it
there's a comment and there's a gender
let's close the script
and also close our
web page
now let's save the file
open a browser and check if a web page
is working correctly
type localhost the name of the folder
and the name of your file
okay so let's write something Mac
Mac x y z added now let's not write
something after it so that the email
address would be wrong just to check one
two three
Dot
C
comment anything would do
gender mail and let's click on submit
so as you can see
it shows enter a valid website URL and
the email address is incorrect let us
also check by writing
an incorrect name that would be Mac one
email address
Mac XYZ at the rate and one two three
dot C
now it's showing the error for the name
too
okay let's write something that is
correct Mac at the rate
gmail.com
website dot pww dot simplylearn.com
comment could be anything
else
and no error sir as you can see we have
got the output
in this video we will learn how to
create a registration page using PHP
HTML some CSS and xam software
then we will use that data and store it
in a mySQL database
so let us begin and start writing a code
first now to do that
we need to go to my computer C drive
now Zam folder this is the folder where
the Zam software is installed
her locate to HD Docs
and let us now create a folder for our
tutorial and name it tutorial
now we'll open this folder in Visual
Studio code
and start writing a program so let us
create a first file here and name it
register Dot
HTML now this will be the HTML file that
is the whole structure of how a
registration page will look
foreign
[Music]
page now this will be the title
of a web page
I think that's enough
now let us move on to the
body of the page
now I'm going to write register in an H1
point
for the heading and now we'll create a
form
function would be
the name register dot PHP
and method
for three post
okay so the first label that I'm going
to create will be for the username
so in a registration form I'm going to
keep it simple I'm just going to include
three categories that would be username
password and a third one would be email
so
to create a label for
username
so you always have to keep in mind
whatever name you're giving here or in
the database whichever you write first
since the name has to match
so I'm giving username the name username
and that's it for a label
now let us create another label
for
before that
input type for this
will be
text
name has been already written will be
username
placeholder with display
and I'm going to put this field as
required which means that the user
cannot leave this field empty
second one would be
label for password
foreign
type
as
password
and you'll know the reason later
you can also give input type of the
password as text but it will not be
secure then
password
ID will be
and this is also a required field
now let us move on to the label or last
section that will be email
and
keywords input type
email yes and email can be set as an
input type
and then email
placeholder will display
email
and you guessed it right this is also a
required field
I think
this is it for the registration HTML Now
we move on to creating our CSS page in
order for this HTML structure to Loop
code
well wait a second I left up of a pretty
important section of the registration
form that is the register button itself
so let me just
not form let me just create
the
registration
for
registration button it will be of type
submit
and value
displayed for three
register
now we'll move on to creating the CSS
file
and let us create a new file and name it
style.css
so the code for style.css is already
prepared so instead of writing the
entire code line by line I'm just going
to paste it and
you can see how it works
so this is the CSS code that will make a
registration form look a little better
so I have created different sections
for different sections of the
registration form so this will be the
registration form input button
this is for the color of the submit
button
and
the rest of the form as you can see now
in order for this style.css file to work
we need to link this file
style.css to
register.html now how do we do that
we'll go on to the register.html back
and we add
just
one extra line in the head of the
program
so here what we are doing is we are
referencing our style.css page into this
page itself
okay
now that's it now both of these pages
that we've just created are linked to
each other and now
at least a registration form
structure is complete it does not work
yet but it will soon
now before creating the register dot PHP
code
let us first create our database so that
we have some understanding of what is
going on around everything so to create
a database what we need to do is
open xaml
start the Apache and MySQL server
now go to your browser
and open the localhost phpmyadmin
now create a new database
let us name it
form
click on create
now let us name our table as users
number of columns would be
4.
the First Column will be ID
which will be Auto incremented
second will be username make sure to use
the same name that we have used in the
code so that
the code does not malfunction
it will be your type variable character
password
will also be a variable character
mail
and now
so as you can see this is the structure
of our
table
of a database form
now let us move on to finally writing
the rest of the code for our
registration form
so now that we have a database complete
let us move on to that to our code and
create the register.php file
wow now the first thing that we need to
do while creating the PHP code is we
need to connect our code with the
database that we just created so this is
why I stopped in between and created a
database so that you need you understand
better how this code is functioning
foreign
host
since
we are using Sam to locally host a
server this will be localhost
our user will be the root user
foreign
since we have not set any password on a
database it will be empty
and finally
the name of a database
what did we name our database
it was formed
foreign
to
connect
to connect a database
with a code
so we have created host
user
password
and finally
name
now we have got to add an error message
which will check if
the database is connected or not
so
will be
[Music]
foreign
now let us add some code
to check if any variable is
empty or not
okay
foreign
is left empty while filling the
registration form it will display the
following message empty field
now let us add another
if code and check
um
foreign
so now that we have added validation
into a code
now what we need to do next is
check whether the username or the
details that have entered that the user
has entered the registration form
already exists or not and if it does
display an error message and if the
details are new enter the details into
our database
now to do that
let us write another if statement
now here I am writing
an SQL command which will select
ID
password from users that is the name of
a table where username and here we are
going to check if the username entered
still exists or no
foreign
which means username already exists so
we need to display
an error message that would be username
already exists
try
again
and if it does not
now in this else part we will be writing
the code
for to send our data into the database
now here
instead of selecting we are going to
insert the data into users which is a
table
and the fields will be username
password
email
and that's it
now the password variable
is going to fetch
the details
of the password field
oh
foreign
email
add another statement
XC execute
and display another message now since we
have entered the data into the database
we need to display a for the message too
foreign
[Music]
this will display
an error message in case something goes
wrong
and now
since we have completed this part of the
code
let us in a statement
oh
foreign
so now that our code is complete now let
us run the code and check if it works
fine
so
our Apache server is running
let's go back to a browser
open the localhost name of the folder
so as you can see register pages are
visible here
register.html and create
a user
turnip
at the rate and
dot com
if you have successfully registered and
you can now login so
let us now check if it's visible in our
database
so our database is forms
users
and as you can see the
file that we just created Tony is
visible here in a database along with
the email and one thing that you may
notice is that the password is not
visible here since we use the hash
protection for passwords so passwords
will not even be visible to the database
admins
so this is how you create a registration
form with the help of HTML PHP xam and
mySQL database
in this tutorial we'll create a simple
login system using PHP and MySQL now
this tutorial is comprised of two parts
in the first part we'll create a login
form and in the second part we'll create
a local also we will show you how to
create a database in order to access the
login webpage as well now first things
first let us quickly go to C Zam htdocs
and create a folder let's name it demo
and quickly open our Visual Studio code
now for this tutorial we'll be creating
a set of files for different functions
now there will be six in total let us
first create these files and we'll write
the code later now the first file would
be
index.php now this is the file that will
be responsible for the login page where
we'll enter a username and password to
login now the second file would be
login.php now now this file will be
responsible for how our login system
will work similarly there will be a
logout file that will be responsible for
how our logout function will work next
would be
home.php now this is the file for our
home page when we login into our account
next would be a file to link our web
page to the database that would be
database connection dot PHP and finally
We'll add a CSS file to make the page
look better now let's get on to writing
a code first let's begin with index.php
now in this page we will create
the login page
let's add the title as login
now here I am going to link this page to
the CSS file that we are going to write
later
you know in this reference
will refer it to the style.css file we
created
let's create a form now since login.php
is responsible for how a login page will
work we will link this index.php to
login.php
method would be post let us add a
heading
login
now this part of the code will be
checking for error and displaying error
if something wrong happens
now we will
add r
username and password fields
let's add another label for password
input type would also be password
now let us add the login button
it would say login
and our form here
now our index.php code is complete now
let's move on to
login.php and
write its code
now what we're going to do is we are
going to connect this page with the
database page
now here we will be validating the data
entered in the form
let us create a variable
for username and password
make sure not making any spelling
mistakes otherwise
you will run into errors
now what this code is doing is it's
checking if there's an entry in the
username and password field and if it is
empty it will display the message as
username is required
similarly what we're going to do is we
are going to create an elsif that would
check if the password field is empty and
display an error message
in a similar way
now that is set up let's import our data
from a database now we have not created
the database yet but we'll write the SQL
query and we'll create a database later
now what I'm going to do is I am going
to name my table as users so here I am
writing select star from users where
user name
would be the value we passed and
similarly password could also be the
value that b
pass
now this is where if the password and
username match with what we have in a
database it will display a message as
logged in
now we are going to create a session
that would be a login session
now ID will also be a field in a
database that would be Auto incremented
and work as the primary key
okay if function is complete
time to write the else part
now the else part would be if the
username or password you have entered
does not match with the one we have in a
database so it would display incorrect
username or password as the error
message
location will be same index.php
so now we have our login.php file also
complete now let's get on to our
home.php file and quickly write the code
for it we will start the session
now this would be our home page
let us also link it to the
CSS file
dot CSS
now with this PHP script we will display
the username of the person that's logged
in so suppose my username would be Mac
so it would display hello Mac we will
very soon see the Practical demo for it
too
now we will link this home page with the
logout session that is
logout.php and
and this
okay so home.php is also complete so
next would be to work on the lower part
now this is a very small code since it
is only working to end any session that
has been created
now first unset the session and then
destroyed
now can you guess the location
it would be
index.php now see this is all the code
for the logout file now finally we will
move on to database connection file
where we will connect our entire web
page these entire four files to the
database
so we are going to create variables for
let us name it since we have already
used you name for username now this is
the name for the server and since we are
hosting a server locally it is localhost
now the next variable would be for the
name of the
okay let us let us change the spelling
this would be name of the default
database
password would be blank since by default
there is no password and this is the
name of the database that we are going
to keep now let us keep the name of a
database as test underscore database
now we'll pass the variables that we
just created
now we will check if the connection that
we have created is
working or not and if not we will
display a message as connection field
now all of our files are complete the
only thing left is style dot CSS now
since style dot CSS is only for the
looks of the of the web page and is not
a very necessary file for a login
function I will just copy paste the code
that I have already written and let us
now move on to creating a database now
to do that first open Zam control panel
and go to your browser and type okay
localhost go to PHP my admin and click
on new database now the name that we
wrote for the database in our code was
test underscore DB so we will have to
name it the same here too database has
been created the table name would be
users number of columns would be three
the First Column would be for the ID and
it will be Auto incremented Now ID will
act as also the primary key for this
table second would be user name
100 would be okay and the third would be
password now as you can see our table
users has been created with ID username
and password now let us open our login
page now this is our login page so to
login we first need some credentials in
the database now we don't have that kind
of time to go on and create a
registration page for it too so let us
just manually add one or two records
into the database from here phpmyadmin
itself so now what we're going to do is
we are going to this insert section and
under the username let us type Mac and
password would be one two three four
five so let's go back to browse and as
you can see we have a credentials here
Mac password is one two three four five
so let's add just one other simply learn
its password would be a b c d e and yes
so we have both of our credentials now
now let's go to the login page and try
to login with the credentials that we
just created so okay let us first enter
a wrong password to check if our error
messages are working correctly
yes absolutely so it's showing incorrect
username of password since the password
I entered was incorrect now let us leave
this username blank and some random
password so it is showing username is
required so a program is working
perfectly now let's enter the correct
credentials and yes so this is our home
page and it is showing hello with the
username that have logged in mac and now
we have got that logout button which
will end this session and take us back
to the login page now let's try to login
to our second account
and hello simply learn we will learn
what is rest API with PHP now let's get
started
now suppose you want to create a weather
app for weather forecast in your area
now to do that you have to set up
supercomputer and a satellite to monitor
the real-time weather
but I wish everyone could be that rich
now for those who cannot afford the
setup you can get the same information
from an existing web service using an
API
now an API acts as a medium between a
web service and your application which
helps you communicate your requests with
the service and get a response
so in this video we'll be learning about
what is rest API principles of rest API
how does a rest API work and finally
creating a sample recipient with the
help of PHP
now let's move on and see what exactly
is rest API
API stands for application programming
interface
Now API is a set of protocols which acts
as a medium of communication between
programs in other words it is a way to
programs talk to each other
now let us understand this with an
example
suppose you the client go to a
restaurant to eat now here the
restaurant is supposed to be the server
how do you communicate your order to the
kitchen
here the waiter comes in the picture
now here the waiter acts as a medium
between you the client and restaurant
the server to send your request to the
kitchen and get food in return as per
requested
this is exactly what an API does
so now that we have an understanding of
API let us look at what rest means in
rest API
now rest stands for representational
State transfer
it is an architectural style which
defines a set of Protocols of how an API
is written
now
rest follows a set of principles for the
design and development of an API
now it is a very efficient technology as
rest takes less bandwidth over similar
other Technologies
so now that we know what rest API is let
us move on to understanding the
principles on which a rest API is
designed
now the first principle is client server
the second stateless third cachable
both uniform interface
fifth layered system and sixth code on
demand
now let us understand these principles
one by one
client server
a res API design works on the concept
that the client and server should be
isolated from one another
and develop independently
this helps in increasing manageability
across various platforms
stateless now according to this
principle rest apis should be stateless
which means calls can be made
independent of one another also every
request sent from the client to the
server must include all the info needed
to comprehend the request
cache bill this principle states that a
rest API should be able to hold cachable
data the data in the response should be
indirectly or directly categorized as
cachable or non-cashable
uniform interface according to this
principle there should be a uniform
interface across all devices and
platforms for the interaction between
application and server
layered systems now rest api's
architecture includes several layers
that operate together to construct a
hierarchy that helps generate a more
scalable and flexible application
now due to the rest API layered system
the application has better security as
components in each layer cannot interact
outside the subsequent layer moreover it
balances loads and offers shared caches
for stimulating scalability
now the last code on demand now this is
optional but this principle allows for
coding to be communicated through the
API as executable code to the client to
be used within the application
we now know on what principles an API is
designed now let us see how an API work
now rest API makes use of HTTP methods
to implement various tasks based on the
client risk request
so the HTTP method uses grid to perform
various operations on the server
crud hair stands for create
read update and delete
now in case of HTTP methods post method
is used to create get method to read
data put method to update it and delete
method to delete data
so I hope you have some understanding of
what risks apis are principles on which
they are designed and how do they work
now let us move on to creating a sample
risk API with the help of PHP
so first let us open the Zam control
panel
and start our Apache and MySQL servers
now what I'm going to do is I am going
to
create
a database
format API
let us name it API
and let us name the
table as users
it will have four columns
first one would be ID integer and it
will be Auto incremented
the second let us name it as name
third would be
age
and finally email
now name would be a text an email will
also be a text
let us quickly save this
and now we have a table for us
now let us add some data into the table
so
Mac
it would be 21 email could be math at
the rate xyz.com
now
let us create another entry
it could be simply learn
page
email
simply learn xyc.com
now as you can see we have added two
rows
with the data that we just entered
now let us move on to the visual studio
code and
see exam htdocs
and
let us create a new folder let's name it
API
and
open with Visual Studio code
let's create a new file let us name it
tutorial
dot PHP
and now let us start writing a code
now first what I'm going to do is I am
going to connect my database
with this code
now since the database is locally hosted
it will be localhost
root
since there's no password this field has
to be empty now
what was the name of the database that
is API
that is what we have to enter here
now this is a variable
to get the response from the server
for the database
okay there's something wrong
now it seems like my opening curly
braces key is not working so I had to
open this on-screen keyboard
we don't need you right now
now let us create another variable named
SQL
foreign
this command will select all the data
from our table users
users
again we're going to need the curly
braces
foreign
as a counter and I am going to give it a
value of 0. now let us create a while
loop and in this while loop
I am going to
fetch the data
and display it in Json format
foreign
now we are going to write the names of
all the
rows that we created in a table
I'm just going to copy paste it
otherwise we'll have to use this
on-screen keyboard again and again
second one was
name
age and email
now what I'm going to do is
I will
plus plus the counter
now to display it is in in Json format
we have to write
this name code
with response
foreign
let us go and quickly
save a code
open a browser
go to the localhost API this is the fold
that we created
now as you can see our tutorial.php is
visible here and when you click on it
you can see the data from the database
being extracted
with the help of API in Json format in
this video on PHP web development we
will learn how to create a website with
the help of PHP
we'll also be using HTML CSS bootstrap
and MySQL in this tutorial so get ready
to create your very own website
now before we get started with the
step-by-step tutorial let me give you a
glimpse of website that I'll be building
in this video
so let me just quickly go to my browser
and type in localhost followed by the
name of the folder where I have created
the website
so I'll be making a photo gallery
website like this
so in case you're a photographer you can
build a similar website in order to
Showcase your talent and if not you can
always create your own personal website
for anything you're passionate about
so without any further delay
let's get right onto a tutorial
so first things first let me show you
the environment that we'll be working on
while creating a website
so we are going to be needing
two softwares that is
Visual Studio code that we'll be using
as our ID the code editor
and the second one would be Zam
now xampp is a web server solution
package which we generally use in order
to manage a database and create a local
web server
you can download it from these
respective websites
since I've already downloaded downloaded
both of the softwares so
we'll be skipping that
now let us begin so after that you've
installed both of these softwares just
go to your C drive
locate exam folder
and inside the Zam folder look for HD
Docs and inside this hddox
name a folder you can name it anything
I'll be naming it photo since I'm
creating a website regarding photos
and then right click inside this folder
and click on open with code
so this opens up our Visual Studio code
and as you can see our photo folder is
visible here
now also one thing that we need to do is
go back to this photo folder right click
and create two new folders first one
would be CSS so it's considered a good
practice even if you're using a single
just a single CSS file it is considered
a good practice to create a separate CSS
folder inside your project folder
also create another folder and name it
images so this is where we'll be keeping
all the images for the website
so let us go back to visual studio code
so as you can see both of these folders
are now visible here
now go on and click on new file
the first file that we are going to
create is index.php
and inside this index.php we'll be
writing the code for the main page of a
website
so let us start
bus
click on an exclamation mark and as you
can see a block of code already written
is
visible here now so
we just need to add a few things
because
that is put the title the title would be
of course
photo
gallery
next up we need to add a few links to
our webpage in order for it to function
well so
the first link would be
foreign
this is a link to
link this page to bootstrap
you can also easily find it on the
internet
or you can just
type in from here
let me just go to the browser to check
if this link is working
yeah
seems fine to me
foreign
link to it
now this link will be for the link for a
CSS file that we'll be creating later on
since we'll be
putting that CSS file inside a CSS
folder I am going to link it to
style.css
so that's it we are done for the first
part of our code now let's
end this head section
and
move on to the body section of our web
page so inside this body section what we
first need is
to add a few Scripts
for our page which will be responsible
for the design of a web page
so
these are the three Scripts that I'll be
linking to our webpage you can just
look and write them as it is
also keep these three scripts at the end
of your body so
any code that we'll be writing inside
body will be above these three Scripts
now let's
design the web page
so the first thing that we'll be needing
is a navigation bar in a webpage so let
us quickly go to the browser
so instead of writing an entire big
block of code
we can just copy it from the internet
so
bootstrap provides you with many such
designs so what we're going to do is we
will type in nav bar
bootstrap
and hit enter
so as you can see
just scroll down and as you can see this
is the navigation bar
which this code will display
also there are different Navigation bars
according to your need along with the
code so you can just copy any of the one
you like I'm going to be copying this
one
click on copy
go back to the code and just paste it
so now what we have here is our
navigation bar ready
so let us go to the browser and check
how does our webpage look so after the
localhost what we're going to do is we
will write the name of the folder in
which we are writing a project which is
photo
well there seems to be some problem
since this nav bar is lacking the CSS
design let us go back to our code and
see
what went wrong
well yes this CSS file that will be
linked
here after CSS there is not a dot but a
slash
I think it should work fine now
well the problem still persists
let me go back and recheck
well yeah I've made some spelling error
here
this is bootstrap not bot strap
and let us go back
reload
and yes as you can see our navigation
bar is
compel and good
let's go back and make some changes to a
navigation bar the first change that I'm
going to be making is I will change the
color theme of the nav bar to
dark not mark
go back reload
and looks better
now
here
go to gallery
good
also
since I'll be using the drop down menu
it is absolutely up to you if you want
to use it or not since I'll be using it
I'll just change the
name
to categories
and the three category
will be the first is
nature photo photographs
the second would be
architecture
and the third
would be
travel
so let's go back
refresh categories nature architecture
and travel so this travel looks a little
different from this nature and
architecture
so as you can notice this this line that
is dividing this section to this section
so let's go back so that line
comes from this part of the code so
we'll just copy
and paste it here
looks good
now that we're back we don't need
this disabled and the search bar
so I'll be removing that
particular part of the codes
and this form two
go back to the browser refresh
and all of the parts of the
navigation bar that we don't need I now
have now been removed
also this link would be for
about section of the web page and we
will also add another section or another
link that would redirect us to the
contact part of the webpage so to do
that to add another link we will just
copy this code
and paste it
and instead of about
this will be contact
go back
refresh home contact about categories so
this categories should come before these
two
so
what we're going to do is we will just
copy this section of the code
and put it after the drop down menu
right
now go back
refresh
will be copyright instead of
cutting it so
it's now visible twice
reload
home categories contact and above
looks perfect
so you see now that's the beauty of
building a website you don't have to
write the entire code by yourself there
are codes already written for all these
kinds of stuff this navigation bar the
carousel that I'm going to be using in
the website the blocks of photos that we
are going to display
on the web page and a lot of design
templates you can call them have already
been written for you to use them instead
of wasting your time and writing the
entire long blocks of code
now next up what I'm going to do is I'll
just go back to our
photo folder and inside this images
I'll just copy the images that I've
already downloaded
copy
go
back
images and paste it here
so now that we have our photos inside
the images folder
let's go back to our code and
write a carousel code or just copy it
from the bootstrap
go back to bootstrap
here
look for carousel
so as you can see
this is what a carousel looks like so a
big photo in on the front of your web
page as you already saw when I showed
you the website
these are the different types of
carousels available on the bootstrap
website you can use any of them
so
the first one is just a single photo
second one
if slides of photos third is slides
photos with this marking
and the final one would be all of them
combined with captions so of course
we'll be using the final one
so copy the code for the final
Carousel or whichever one you like and
go back to your code and here after this
navigation bar
paste your calendar code
click on Save
go back
and refresh
so since we haven't added any images
here
there are none visible but you can see
this
Carousel has been added to our webpage
so
let's go back and now we are going to
add the images that we just
pasted in this images folder
so in this Carousel code
look for image SRC so this is the
location
of the image that will be displayed so
type in images that is the name of the
folder from where you'll be picking up
the images
for Slash and
let me just go back to this images
architecture port
yep
so architecture four
in this Alt
type in architecture and here is the
heading so this is part of the caption
of the Carousel so I'll be writing
arcade texture here and I'll make this
heading a little bigger
it's three I think H3 would do
and I don't want to add any more
descriptions if you do you can write all
of that inside this paragraph but I
won't be so I'll just move it from here
I'll do the similar
with
this
so
what we're going to do is we will write
images
slash and go back
what image I'm going to be adding nature
four would do
in nature
or
type in
nature
similar
to what we did above H3
H3 remove this
foreign
here the last one would be
travel
H3
H3 and let me just
type in the
travel five
and in this Alt
type
travel
and we are good to go
okay let's reload
and voila so our images are visible here
with this beautiful carousel and you can
forward them and
well
does this not look beautiful to you
so architecture
nature
can travel
but as you can see we have some problem
here the images are way too big to fit
on this part of the screen and it's
going all the way down
and this part of the carousel is not
visible on the main page when someone
opens a website with absolutely does not
look good so
what we're going to do for it
now to fix this what we're going to do
is we will go back to our code editor
inside the CSS folder
we will create the file that we linked
at the start of a tutorial
style.css and here
just
write this code margin
adding also zero
and
box sizing
would be border box
so now to display the images
on the just on the main page of a
website what we're going to do is we
will
put a dot go back to the main index.php
and from here
copy this name of the class Carousel
item
go back to style.css
paste it here cancel item
and type IMG
and inside this
we will Define the width and the height
of the image so the width would be 100
and we are going to keep the height at
The Edge so that it does not go beyond
the webpage
let us quickly save it go back
reload
and yes
it looks great
and it's also visible on our screen now
now next up what we're going to do is we
will be creating different sections on
this very webpage
for the different categories that is
nature architecture and travel
so go back to the code
under this
Carousel code
let us start writing our first section
that would be
section
class
so
I'll be using
my 4 and Pi 4
the first div
so what we want is we want the text to
be in the center of the page so
the class would be text Center
and
the first category is nature
now the next thing that we need to do is
we need to add the images to it so how
do we do that
also we are not to display a single
image on a on the entire web page what
we need is we need to display small
three blocks of images in a row so
we need to create another div
class and inside the class we will
Define the column for large
systems
for the mid ones
and for the mobile devices
so
after you have written this class after
you written this div the images
doesn't matter the size of the screen
only
three images will be displayed on a
large and middle screen and a single
image will be visible when opened on a
mobile phone so all in all your website
would be very responsive to all the
devices that you will be using
let's just close it and inside this tip
what we're going to do is we will link
our image
and
the image would be since this is nature
let's use nature one which image we have
we have already used in the carousel
nature4 so let's skip that
and
put the class as
fluid
and padding bottom padding would be
three
well I think it's done so this is the
first section let's go to our page
refresh
so nature and our first image is also
visible here so what we need is we need
to display two more images in this row
go back
and it's now I'll copy and paste
just note this part
this part of code
copy
paste
and paste so
now
nature two
and nature 3.
go back refresh
okay this seems to be a problem here
let us figure out why this is happening
okay we forgot to add the
road if
and without the row div the images will
not be displayed in a row but of this
so
container
fluid
I'm using this since just a second
let me paste it here
and
we will create another div
named row
and our entire code will go inside it
and we'll paste it
let's go back and check if it changes
anything
and it does so our images are displayed
perfectly
our first section that is nature for a
category is complete now now next what
we need to do is
I think you guessed it we just need to
copy this section
and paste it
twice
since there are two more sections
so after the first section in the second
one would be for
architecture
the images we need to change
architecture one
architecture two and
architecture three
yeah
refresh
nature architecture and well nature
again because we did not edit the third
part of the code
so the third part of the code
will be for travel
let us quickly
add the images so travel to
travel 4 and I
think we use travel
five already
so
travel six
and go back
refresh
and travel images architecture and
nature so
half of our website is already done guys
now what we need to do is we need to
create two more sections for the contact
and about
so for the contact part of the web page
we'll be needing a form that we will
then go on and link to a database that
we'll be creating later on and the about
section will be responsible to give some
information regarding the website
regarding the photographer that have
uploaded these images
so let's go back to our code and
move on to creating another section for
the contact
so
with let me just copy only in this
section of the code
and of course
foreign
needing a closing tag
this will be
contact us
and let's
create another div
class would be
and M
Auto so why I'm doing this is because
inside the contact will be creating a
form where there will be columns and to
manage the width and margin of these
columns I am writing the class for it
inside the step
we will write a form
inside the form the first thing that we
need is action
and the action for the form will be
about dot PHP this is a file that we'll
be creating later on
and the next thing is method which will
be post
let's close this
create another div
class named
form group
okay
from group
close it
inside this
I'll write a label that would be
name
this will be our first column input
type
text of course
let's give it a name so this is very
important so the name that you're going
to write here
should be
matching should be matching with the
name in the database
and class
form control
foreign
this
paste and
paste so the second section would be for
email
type will also be
the name will also be email
third would be for the number
let us keep the type text in case
someone wants to enter the
sud code
and let's go back refresh
check
contact us the fields are visible now
what we need is a submit button
so after this step let me
create a button
type
submit
class so this will make the button look
green adding some
CSS
and
the button would be called submit
go back refresh
submit button is here
now let us also create a section for the
about part of the page and then we'll
move on to making a database
so to do that what we need to do is
we'll just copy this section
for the about
paste it here
close the section
and here let's start writing the code
foreign
container
fluid so why are we using this container
fluid class is because sometimes when
you don't use this class the images or
text from your web page tends to
create so you can see a scroll bar here
vertically it tends to create another
scroll bar horizontally which we don't
want
so container fluid
close the step
inside it
let me create a class
text
Center
it will say the name Mac
let me just give some space
and write a paragraph
with a class of course text
Center
otherwise if the text will start from
the extreme left it would look weird
and
close it
let's add some bold
and write
let's see
I am
passionate
photographer
[Music]
interested
in networking
architecture
nature and
travel
photography
next would be
[Music]
um
full time freelancer
build an experience of five years
well I think this would do
refresh
oh we did not change this we'll just get
right on to it contact us I'm a
passionate photographer interested in
working architecture nature travel
photography freelancer and all of the
things that we should just written about
Mac
we just need to change this to
about
and I think we're done
yes
so our web pages almost complete guys
now we need to do some
changes
or add some things so the first thing
that we'll be adding is
and
about dot PHP file
and inside this above.php file we will
be creating a connection with our
database and fetching the data from it
for sending the data from our form to
the database so before that let's go
back
to the browser type in localhost
followed by PHP my
admin
click enter
but before that
you must
open Zam control panel and start the
Apache server and MySQL server since I
already did I did not show you the sets
so after the MySQL server has been
started you can see this PHP my admin
panel and from here we can create
databases
so inside this phpmyadmin click on new
and let us name our database as
photography
click on create
now what we are going to do is we will
create a table where the data will be
stored from our form
let us name the table as users number of
columns would be four
the First Column would be course ID
which will be Auto incremented
the second column would be name
type variable character 250
third is email
also variable character 250 and the
final was our number
variable character
and click on Save
so as you can see the structure of our
table
the table users has been created inside
the database photography now we need to
go back to our code and write the code
PHP code to connect our form to this
database
uh
foreign
to connect
the database
since a server is locally hosted the
name of the server would be
localhost
root
that is the default
now if
connection
so this if condition will check if the
connection is successful or not and if
successful display
connection
successful
next
also add if the connection is not
successful we should always have an
error message connection
failed
next what we need to do is we need to
mysqli
select underscore
BB
and inside this
we need to mention the name of our
database which is
photography
let's just go back and recheck
because the name is very important if
you
mess with the name the entire code goes
to win
now let me create some variables which
will fetch
the data
from the form in order to send them to
the database so
let's keep the same names so that we
don't
create any confusion
email and of course
number
post
so now that we have our variables we
need to run
a
query
so
since we are patching the data from the
form and inserting it into a table we
need to run a query for insert
into the name of the table that is users
and then
name
email
number
followed by the values that
will be
giving them
so notice this is the name of the
fields that you've given in your table
and this is these values are these
variables that we've just created
so
inside it
name
second would be
email and third would be
number
I think the query is done now
to check if it works
we will run another query
and I am going to add a header file here
because once you click on submit button
let me just go back
so if you click on submit button here
the page will redirect
to a different page which will just
display connection successful we don't
need that we need to stay on this page
itself so in order to do that
I am writing this header file with the
location
[Music]
of index.php
enter and I think we are done here
now let's go back and add some details
Mac Mac add to it simply
learn.com
[Music]
zero click on submit
go back to your database
click on browse and if the connection
would be successful you can see the data
here and we can Mac email and number
that's great so
now let's move on to the final section
of the website
so how do we make this categories
nav bar work
well it's pretty simple we just need to
redirect to a section of a web page
whenever clicked a button so when we
click on nature we need a web page to be
redirected to this section
so
let's just go back to our code and what
we're going to be doing is we will
create links just a second
for every section of our webpage so
let's go back to the first section that
is
nature
and here
right
give it an ID
so the ID for this section would be
nature
close the tag
cut and paste it here so as you can see
this ID
this section of our web pages enclosed
in this ID so now with this a tag we can
refer our this section of the web page
to any button
similarly
we will add
another ID here
so the ID would be
architecture course
make sure the spellings are correct
put it after the section
now
go back a ID
this would be
travel
okay
just a second
cut it
paste it here
again
what I'm going to do is instead of
writing it again and again I'll just
copy it from here
is it
since this is contact us let me just put
on
contact here contact yeah
and the section
right
and this will be
of course about
yes good now what we need to do is we
need to refer these sections with the
respective IDs to the buttons go back to
the navbar code on your web page
so here is a nav barcode so inside it
you can see after every button there's a
reference you just need to add the name
of your ID
do not remove this
and
architecture
travel
contact
and
about
let's go back refresh
click on categories
okay
what happened here okay no
nature yep
travel yep
contact
about so everything works perfectly now
so while we're added let me just okay
let me first show you
um Rob
at the rate
dot com one two three four five five
five five
click on submit
so as you can see whenever you click on
submit it redirects you to the front of
the web page
I don't want that
yeah the database is working so just go
back to the about.php and here we added
the header location
index.php so it is redirecting
with
code to the
start of the web page what we need to do
is we need to redirect it to a
particular section that is contact so
just add
contact in front of it
save
go back
scroll down
Tony
[Music]
Stark
industries.com
click on submit
and as you can see after you click on
submit the page does not go back to the
starting it just stays here while the
data has been submitted
to our database
now that we have completed our website a
quick question for you guys
if you were asked to create a website
based on your interests what would the
website be about
let us know in the comment section below
now let me show you a glimpse of the
website we'll be creating which is
called techbad.com
but you can obviously create a website
for the product of your choice so let me
just go to the browser
type in
localhost website and this is the
website that we'll be creating this is a
very basic website for e-commerce
services but as you can see we have
displayed the top products on the front
page of a website and here from the drop
down menu you can see laptops and phones
so without wasting much time let's get
started now before we begin let me tell
you that we'll be using visual studio
code as the IDE our code editor and Zam
as the web server Solutions package
which will be hosting a local server
server for the website
now another thing that we need to do
before beginning
is we need to go to a browser
and type in
bootstrap download
go to this website
and from here
download the boots tab
file
this will be a compressed file you can
download it from here and I'll tell you
later what we're going to do with it
now let's go and set up a coding
environment
so let me just close this
go to C
um folder
locate hdocs folder in it and
create
any name for your project
I'll be writing website
and inside this website what you're
going to do is
go to your downloads now this bootstrap
folder that we just downloaded we are
going to extract it
inside that
website folder
so
let's just go back
we need them outside
delete this
so as you can see we have got a CSS and
JS folder and we'll be using this in a
website
now
let us begin our code
so right click
open the code
now this is our Visual Studio code and
as you can see our website folders
visible here and from here we can create
a new file so our first file would be
index dot PHP
now let's start a code
type in exclamation mark and hit enter
and you can see this block of code will
be visible here
now we need to add a few things
well not a few quite a lot first would
be title
the title would be
well
since my website is stacked by I'm going
to give the title as Tech by
next what we're going to do is we are
going to add
some links
to this index.php
foreign
so these are the links for the CSS files
present inside this folder that we just
downloaded from bootstrap
and we'll be linking some of the files
from this folder onto
our website so that the website looks
good yeah
now the reference would be CSS this is
the folder and
the file is bootstrap
dot Min dot CSS so this is the first
file that we're going to be linking
next
let's add
a script here
so this is a pretty popular script and
you can find it on the internet easily
foreign
let me just recheck if I type
it correctly
yeah seems fine
now moving on
we are going to be adding another script
that would be
JavaScript
and it will include boots
jQuery
all right bootstrap
I'm just going to find it bootstrap
dotman.js
here this enter second script
now let us just end
this title
and move on to the body part of the code
now
what do we need to produce or create
first now the first thing that we need
is a navigation bar
so
to create a navigation bar I'll give you
a pretty easy way to do that instead of
writing a hefty big code you need to go
to your browser
since we are using bootstrap why not
take the best out of it now type in
bootstrap never
go to this link never bootstrap
and as you can see this bootstrap this
nav bar can be
access using this code
just copy it go back and paste it in
your body
now we'll be making a few changes to a
navigation bar according to our
e-commerce website but before that we
need to check if this navigation bar is
visible correctly on the web page now to
do that
first
let's open a Zam control panel start our
Apache server
and go to a browser now to see the
result of your code to see if this code
that you've just written
is how does it look on a web page we
need to type in localhost followed by
the name of the folder that you created
for your project since the name of my
folder is website I've written website
here click on enter
and will navigation bar looks a bit
weird
there's no designing to it now let me go
back to the code and see what I did
wrong
well yeah
we don't need this bootstrap reboot dot
Min dot CSS instead we need just
bootstrap.mn.css
let's save it go back and reload
well our navigation bar is visible let's
go back to the code and start making
some of the changes the first change
that I'm going to be making is I will
change the color theme of this
navigation bar
and yeah looks much better
now let me remove
some things first
let's change the name to techby.com
well
second
let us let it be home
so this is the drop down I will be
changing it to products
the first product is
laptop
the second one
phones
we don't need this here
and
let me put the divider
and between
we don't need this
disable part either
and neither do we need the search form
now I want to make a few changes to the
navigation bar so this navigation bar
seems a little thin
let me add
just a little bit of breadth to it
yep
looks good
and as you can see laptops phones and
this dividing line
now what we need to do is create a front
page that is the top featured content on
the front page that will be visible on
our eCommerce website so to do that
create a div class
let us name it
and
this will be a column div inside this
another div class
this will be for the row
and now
just a second
yes
this will also need a class since we've
won our text in the center of the page
and
top products
okay
let me just add some spaces
well
before adding those
images and the products onto our page we
need to prepare a little bit more so
before that let us just save this piece
of code and
see how does it look so it displays top
products in the center of the page looks
great now what we need to do before we
can display the products on this page is
we need to create a database in where we
are going to store all the information
regarding our products and we will fetch
that data from the database and display
it on our website
Now to create the database just go back
to the Zam control panel and start the
MySQL server too
now here type in localhost
PHP
my admin
and you can see you are now redirected
to the PHP my admin control panel where
you can create different databases
so as you can see I've already created a
database named Tech by
under which I have got another table
that is products
with some data here
now I'll show you how to create a
database
from scratch now to do that we need to
go to this new part
now since we already have a tech by
database let us name it something
different e-commerce
and create
now we have created a database named
e-commerce and inside the e-commerce
what we need to do is we need to create
a table
let us create the table and name it
products now a table with Will mainly
consist of around six or seven
columns and let us keep it seven the
first would be ID of course and it will
be Auto incremented
the second
title of the product
which will be a variable character to 55
price of the product
since prices can be
in decimal
let us keep this decimal and
the values would be 10 comma 2.
next is brand name
um
this is variable character
100 would do
image now this
column here will contain the location of
the image on our server or on a system
since our system is the local server so
this will also be a variable character
next would be description
this will be a text since a description
can be long
and last could be featured
all right
let us save this table
and we have our products table here
in our new database that is e-commerce
now we need some images for this image
file for our products now I've already
downloaded some images
let me just
copy them
go back to a C drive Zam
what we are going to do is we are going
back to our website folder
and we'll be creating a new folder
inside the website folder and let us
name it images
and paste your images here
let me go back to
this Visual Studio code and as you can
see our images are visible here
we'll be using them very soon
let us go back to this
and let me add an entry here
so we'll be working with one product and
once you understand the concept you can
add many more products later on so the
title would be
Google pixel 5
the price
65 000 brand name of course Google
image now to add the path of your image
what you need to do is you need to go
back here
images now the path would be inside
website
and inside images folder so
images
and Then followed by the name of the
image since the name for my Google phone
is gpixel
I'll be writing G pixel dot PNG make
sure you do not make a mistake while
writing a name
and in the description
well I've copied some description from
the internet I will be posting the same
here
Google pixel 5 5G 8GB Ram 128 GB
space now inside the featured part
will be numbering it one and click on go
so go back to browse and you can see
your field that you just created visible
here
so now that we have the entry for our
image for our product that is Google
pixel 5 phone in our database let us go
back to the code to see how to retrieve
this information from this database into
our code and display it on our screen
let's go back to our code
and in our code
let's go back to the top
and here we are going to be creating a
PHP
script
and inside that script I will be
accessing the database now
let us create a connection to the
database using my sqli
connect and inside this what we're going
to do is we will be writing the name of
loop the server since the server is
localhost
and then
this
next would be root
now
again
MySQL I
now here select
DB database and inside this
we'll be selecting a database from the
my admin panel
so what we need to do is we need to
write the variable name followed by the
name of the database that we need
information from so uh the name of our
database was
e-commerce yep
so e-commerce
so here we have created a connection
with the database now let us create
another file SQL so
for this this variable will be accessing
all the information stored in our table
products so
we'll be writing some SQL commands
select star that is all the details from
name of our table products let me just
read check
products yep and
where
featured is equals to 1.
so remember that while
creating a entry we put this featured
value as one so
foreign
this part of the code is done now let us
go back down
where we stop last
and
write R
PHP script
so here
what we are going to do is we will be
creating a while loop
now inside the while loop we will create
another
variable as products
which will be equals to my sqli and this
function is used to fetch the data from
the database
and
feature
well there's something that we missed
we did not create the variable featured
here and
well it would have given an error
so what featured would do is featured
reduce the connection to query the
SQL command
now
go back
here
what this while loop will be doing is
this while loop
will be fetching
the data
from our table under the category of
featured number one
so
next what we're going to do is next we
will create another div class
which would be
inside this Edge for another
PHP script
is equals to product
now
inside this we are since this will be
the title we will be displaying the
title from here so what we need to do is
we need to add the title and close the
PHP script here
next
we need to display the image
so here in this image SRC we don't need
to write the path of the image since we
have already entered that into the
database what we need to do is we need
to specify the path from where we need
to fetch the image from the database so
it's pretty simple
again
the same thing
product
and as you would have guessed it
it will be image was it image or images
let me just recheck
it was image
close this close the file
and here we have retrieved our image now
product
inside this product what we are going to
get is the price
title so that if one would hover over
here it will display the title of the
product
and
that's it you need to close it
so set
foreign
looks good
next we will display the price of the
product
to do that
we will create a class let us name it
L price
close it
rupees
we are doing it again product
and
here
we what we need to do is we need to get
the price and close this
similarly
whatever details that we need to display
here from the database we are going to
be accessing them
through this script
with changing the name of the column
that we need to access
so now that we have all this let us
also create a reference page
and I'll be creating another file
details.php which will display the
details of the product
but
before that let me create a button
type button
class
button success
foreign
would be more
and
well this ends here
also what we need to do is we need to
let me
just see what we need to do is we need
to
and this
while loop
and while here
and just
close it
so this div
and this div
everything's good
save
let's go back and see if it's working
and voila we have our first product
displayed here on the front page of our
e-commerce website Google pixel 5 the
phone the more button does not work yet
but we'll be working on it but it feels
good doesn't it
now let us go back to the code and see
how to create this details.php file
first
details.php and inside this file what
we're going to do is we are going to
just copy paste some part of the code
here
and
also
this part of the code
okay
okay and
you don't need it
now we need one or two more things to be
displayed here so just copy this
paste it
and paste it again let's go back to
um
our localhost and what we need to
display here is
so we have already displayed the title
the price
and the image so the things that we're
left with is the description and the
brand name
so let's go back
price is already here
just add test description
and
brand name
was it brand name
yep brand name description
it's good
change
class name here
foreign
so
what we're going to do is we will be
refreshing this page and clicking on
more
and
well yes good the details of our product
are visible here now let's go back and
make a little changes
so the first change would be this so
this would be product details
and
save
click on this still a big gap
yes looks better now
let me just
you can add some bold or italics or
whatever you like
foreign
[Music]
so I've added bold in the title let's
see if it works
I'm not sure if it does
okay since it's already a heading
my bad
let me
add it here
okay
save it so this is the price
and yes price is in bold now so you can
make a few changes to make your
description look better
and let us go back to the main page and
what we're going to do is we are going
to create two new files for this laptops
and phones to display them separately
when we click on any drop down menu
since they don't work yet
let me show you an example to create a
file for this product laptops and you
can create
the rest yourself so first thing that we
need to do is we need to go back to this
database into our table
and
create another entry so the title would
be Asus row laptop
price would be 1 lakh 20 000 brand name
Asus image so the image is website
images and the name of the image is
probe Asus dot PNG
root ASUS dot PNG
and
I've copied some description for the
from the internet
and now the one thing that you need to
notice is we are going to be keeping
this featured part as 2 instead of one
and go back to browse and you can see
the detail that we just created with the
feature number two so now go back to a
code and create another file let us name
it
raw Dot
laptops dot PHP
let me just see
yep I have
so yeah I may have skipped this part so
in the drop down menu when we create a
navigation bar here it was written this
so we need to replace this reference
where the name of the
PHP file that we just created that is
product Dash
laptops.php so Raw
product Dash laptops.php
and inside this
first thing that we need to do is copy
this code paste it here now here change
it to two
and drop down
top products everything looks fine
save it since the feature number will be
two
let us go back
refresh
click on laptops
and here you can see the Asus Rogue
laptop visible now let me add another
product on our feature page that has a
front page to show you how do we display
more than one product with the same code
so
go back to this database and create
another entry
let's say HP laptop price would be 80
000 okay I think I just
created an entry let me delete it
go back
HP laptop price 80
000 brand name HP image website images
name of the image that is HP underscore
laptop dot PNG
HP underscore laptop dot PNG
and the description which I have copied
from the internet and in this feature
we're going to be writing one since we
are displaying this on the front page of
our website
go back to browse here are the details
now let's get back
we don't need to change anything just
save it
go back
and refresh
and as you can see we have our HP laptop
visible here and similarly we can just
re add products into a database and this
single piece of code is enough to
display them all on a web page
Guys these are some of the basics of an
e-commerce website you can add more
products choices more detailed
descriptions and add more designing
using CSS bootstrap cards
and buy sell sections on your website
just play along with the code and start
making your own web pages in this video
we'll discuss some of the frequently
asked questions in PHP interviews now
the questions are categorized in two
sections beginner and advanced questions
so without any further Ado let us get
started with the beginner questions now
the most basic question is what is PHP
so PHP stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into HTML and is
generally used for dynamic web
development phpus also have very
compatible language that is it also
works efficiently with almost 20
different databases such as MySQL
postery SQL
Etc next question what is a session in
PHP now sessions in PHP are used to
store data for users under a unique ID
which can be then used across multiple
web pages of a website next what is peer
in PHP now peer stands for PHP extension
and application Repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of PHP containing code
Snippets and libraries next is PHP
considered a case-sensitive language so
this is a very often asked questions in
interviews
PHP is partially case sensitive since
variables in PHP are case sensitive
while functions and user-defined
functions are not next name different
types of data types in PHP so different
data types in PHP include integer float
string Boolean array object null and
finally resource so there are total
eight different data types that exist in
PHP next question
how is Echo different from print
now Echo it can output multiple strings
at a time while in case of print it can
output only a single string now Echo
does not have a return value while print
always returns 1. that is the reason
that is Echo is faster because it does
not have to return a value while it is
print is slower in comparison to Echo
because it always returns a value now as
you can see both of these commands Echo
and print are used in the exact same way
next what are the rules for naming a
variable now there are certain rules
which you have to follow or certain good
coding practices which you have to
follow while naming a variable in your
PHP code so variable name must always
begin with underscore or a letter so it
cannot begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so suppose you want
to name your variable number one to
three so you can use this variable but
you cannot use number at the rate one to
three since special characters are not
included next a variable in PHP is
declared using this dollar sign followed
by the variable names now as you can see
this is how we declare a variable dollar
my underscore variable you can also put
a number in between or at the end while
naming a variable just not at the start
next name some popular PHP Frameworks so
some of the popular PHP Frameworks
include Symphony code igniter Cake PHP
and laravel moving on
how to check if a defined variable is
null or not so is a thank function is
used to check if the defined variable
has any value or not so to use this
suppose you have this block of code in
front of you so suppose you want to
check if this x variable that you've
defined is null or not so what you do is
you put the is it function inside the if
condition and it will return true if
it's
not null while it will return false if
it is a null value since it is not null
it returns true and we can display Echo
as variable X is not null while in the
case of variable y it is a null value
since so the if condition will be false
and it will not display anything next
how are objects in PHP passed so objects
in PHP are always passed by a value not
by reference next question how to
display output directly to the browser
now in cases you want to display your
output directly onto the browser while
running a piece of code you can use it
use these special tags to display an
output directly to the browser now as
you may notice these tags does not
contain the PHP written you can use them
directly and replace PHP within equal to
sign followed by what you want to
display and end it with a question mark
and a closing bracket moving on what is
defined function used for in PHP now
Define is used to declare a constant in
PHP also in contrast to the variables
there is no need for a dollar sign
before declaring a constant since the
value of a constant does not change
now this is how you can use the defined
function to declare a constant suppose
we want to declare the value of pi as
3.14 throughout your PHP code and which
cannot be changed so we can use Define
for that next question is related to
this question since what is constant
function in use for in PHP then it's a
constant function Returns the value of a
constant it is not used to define a
constant but it Returns the value of a
constant so suppose you define a
function constant using this defined
function and you want to return this
value you can use this constant function
for that next is multiple inheritance
supported in PHP so PHP only supports
single level inheritance which means a
class can be extended from only one
class using the keyword extended now
next what are the different types of
Loops in PHP so PHP consists of a while
loop a do while loop a for Loop and
finally a for each Loop so PHP consists
of total four Loops next question
how to concatenate two strings in PHP
now two strings can be easily
concatenated using the dot operator in
PHP now to do that I'll show you with
the help of a code suppose you want to
concatenate or join these two strings
str1 hello guys and the second string
would be and welcome to Simply learn and
want to display these strings together
so to do that you need to use this dot
operator in Echo as you can see this dot
operator so first you write this name of
the first string Then followed by the
dot operator I've given this space and
then the next dot operator because this
is also considered as a string and then
the third string variable and this is
how you concatenate two strings next
question what is the use of function num
AR argument now this function as you can
see is used to return the number of
arguments passed in a function so
suppose you pass a certain number of
arguments in a function and want to know
how many values or arguments per past
you can use this function for that so
suppose in this sample code you want to
know how many arguments were passed in
this sample function so to do that we
declare a variable number of arguments
and we will equal it to the function of
number function number arguments now we
will display it and this sample has
passed three arguments so the output
would be 3. moving on what are super
Global variables in PHP now some
predefined variables in PHP are known as
super Global variables because they are
always accessible from any function file
or class regardless of the score so in
all in all they are globally accessible
so suppose you write a piece of code and
you declare a variable inside it it
would be a local variable and could be
access only in that part of the code but
in case of super Global variable they
are accessible throughout the entire
code they include Global server request
posts get files EnV cookie and session
moving on how to invoke single line and
multi-line comments now a single line
comment in PHP can be made using this
hash followed by the command or double
slash followed by the comment while in
case of multi-line comments you can use
this hash star and write your comments
in multiple lines and enclose it with a
star and slash what I'm going to do now
is I am going to show you the use of
these comments in actual vs code now let
us take this block of code for example
now suppose you want to add a com single
line comment after this variable so what
you will do is you can use this double
slash this is
uh variable
also you can use slash
this is also a variable so this is a
single line comment now if you try to
write something else after this in the
next line it will take it as part of the
code not part of the comment so what do
you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose you need to write two
three lines about this line of code what
you will do is you'll use a slash star
now write the comment this is displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment which
you can end simply by start and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments now let's move on to
the next question that is name some
common applications of PHP so some of
the most commonly used PHP applications
are system functions form handling so
PHP is very commonly used to handle the
fonts that you see on the web pages
correct tasks now crud tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and PHP is used very commonly in
that next accessing cookies variables
and set keys and finally data encryption
PHP provides security through some of
its Frameworks which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites so now that we have gone
through the beginner level questions
that are frequently Asked in PHP
interviews let us now move on to the
advanced level questions so the first
question would be how can you execute a
PHP script from the command line now a
PHP script from a command line can be
executed by by opening the command line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the PHP file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a PHP underscore
script.php so you type in the name of
the PHP script that you want to run and
that particular PHP script will be
executed next differentiate between a
dollar variable and double dollar
variable so what is the difference
between the two now in case of a single
dollar variable is it is a simple
variable that is simply used to store
data so as we discussed earlier it is a
variable that we Define to store
different data types that is integer
float strings Etc while a double dollar
variable is a reference variable of
variable so this is used to reference
already existing variables now to you
use or to understand how these two work
you can see this particular block of
code here now in this code what you need
to focus on is this is a simple variable
hello which contains the string welcome
to Simply learn and we have defined
another variables as well which contains
a string hello now in this Echo as you
can notice what we are doing is we are
using this also before that you need to
notice is this is the same string as the
name of this variable so first we are
displaying this variable and then we are
referencing this variable here so what
it is doing is it is referencing the
value to another variable so hello
variable is being referenced so when you
execute this block of PHP script what
you get the output is hello since this
is the variable hello and after that
what you'll get is welcome to Simply
learn since this variable is a reference
to this variable
next differentiate between get and post
method now get method is used to submit
form data while post method is also used
for the same feature so the difference
between them is get method sends data as
part of PHP page URL sorry web page URL
while a post method sends data through
HTTP header in get the data since the
data has been sent through the URL it is
displayed in the URL of the web page so
it is not secure while in case of post
method it is a secure form of data
transfer hence When developing a website
for some security purposes usually we
prefer post method next up how to
connect to a database using a PHP script
now suppose
if you are asked this question in an
interview what you need to do is you
need to just write this block of code
and explain it to the interview now
suppose we have a PHP script and we want
to connect it to a database what we need
to do is we will create three different
variables that is server name username
and password now what we're going to do
is we will create another variable con
that will be used to connect it and then
we'll use the mysqli functions which
will then pass these variables to create
a connection so these variable values
are localhost username password these
other default values now to check if the
connection is connected what we're going
to do is we will use an if condition if
the con variable gets and connect error
we will display a error message artist
connection field if not we will display
connected successfully now as you can
see here these names can be the name of
the server that you're trying to connect
I have used localhost username password
for the default values you can use the
name of the database that you're trying
to connect your PHP script to next up
what does final class and final method
mean in PHP now a final class in PHP
means that the class cannot be extended
while a final method means that it
cannot be overridden now as you can see
in this block of code we have used the
final keyword for a class and the final
keyword for a function now suppose he
this final class is being inherited by
this child class what the program will
return is an error because once you use
this final keyword this class cannot be
inherited and similarly suppose this
function is trying to be overridden by
this part of the code it cannot be
because we have used the final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding Now function
overloading the same function is used
for different purposes based on the
number of arguments inside the function
while in case of function overriding the
same name and same argument function is
used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method now let me show you
and demonstrate the difference with an
example so let us look at this code so
suppose you have a function named show
title which does have contain a single
parameter and displays when called upon
using this parameter displays function
1. now if you want to use the same name
of the function for a different purpose
what you can do is you can increase or
change the number of parameters inside
the function that is it now contains two
parameters so when this same function is
called using two parameters it will
function differently and display
function overloading so this is how
function overloading works next from
this piece of code we can understand 1
function overriding suppose you display
a function demo in a base class and you
want to override this demo function
inside the derived class so what you do
is you make another function with the
same name inside the derived class with
some different properties as you can see
it displays something different now you
create an object for the base class and
when you use this Base Class object to
call this demo function you can use the
properties of this function here while
if you create another object that is
object 2 for the derived class and you
use this object to call upon the same
demo function you are overriding this
Base Class demo function that was
inherited instead what it will use is it
will use the properties of the derived
demo function so that is how you over or
override a class function in PHP now
let's move on to the next question that
is differentiate between equal to equal
to and triple equal operator so a double
equal operator is generally used to
check if the value of two operands are
equal or not it is generally used in
case of conditional statements while a
triple equals to operator performs a
type safe comparison which means that
will that it will only return true if
both operands have the same type and the
same value so you can understand this
more with this piece of code so suppose
in this case since they both are equal
it will return true while in this case
they both have done same type hence it
will return true now let us next check
this equals to equal so since they both
are 1 and in PHP it will display as true
since they are equal while when you are
type checking that is you are checking
if they're equal with with the same type
and same value it will display a false
since one is an integer and the other
one is a string value also if you check
two different strings with the type
shape it will also display true next
question
how does exception handling work in PHP
so when an exception is thrown code
following the statement will not be
executed and PHP will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a PHP fatal
error will will be issued with an
unquote exception an exception can be
thrown and caught within PHP so what we
do is we use this try and catch
method to try the code and if an error
occurs we can catch if an exception
occurs we can throw it and the catch
function will catch the exception and if
this we do not include the catch
function it will result in a fatal error
next up differentiate between require
and include now require if a required
file is not found it will throw a fatal
error and stop the code execution while
in case of include if an essential file
is not found it will produce a warning
and still execute the remaining scripts
so as you can see both of these include
and require I use in the exact same way
with different functions next up explain
different types of errors in PHP now PHP
consists of mainly three errors notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it a warning is a critical
error now it is given in condition where
suppose an include function that we just
discussed in the previous question when
to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning and final is a fatal error so
it is a critical error resulting in
termination of the code so as we
discussed in the try and catch part of
the question if an exception is thrown
and we do not have a catch function for
it it will display a fatal error which
will return in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference so
Ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value pass inside the function is
also modified while in case of value the
value of the original value does not
change
so this piece of code here is an example
of how you can call a function by
reference here as you can see this
Ampersand sign will call this function
by reference and any changes made in the
variables here will affect the original
ones next question
create a Singleton class in PHP so how
do we create a Singleton class in PHP
before that let's have a look at what is
a Singleton class now a Singleton class
in PHP is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create different access points into
that block of code
so in a Singleton class you can only
create a single object hence Singleton
so this piece of code as you can notice
is used to create a Singleton class
now in to create a Singleton class you
need to have the Constructor function
private now here as you can see a
Singleton class is created using this
private construct and it then checks if
there's only one instance created and if
it is it functions probably and displays
initialize only once next question how
to encrypt a password using PHP so PHP
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose you create a
password string and enter your password
as password at the rate one two three
and you put it inside the password has
hash function so what it will generate
is we are echoing this generated hash so
what it will generate is
this so this is the This Is Random it
changes every time you generate the
password since it is encrypted and same
when you pass this password to the
database using hashing algorithm even in
the database the password will not be
visible so your data is secure next
question mention different sorting
functions for arrays in PHP now let us
understand this question in the vs code
so PHP consists of different sorting
functions which you can use to sort and
given array automatically so if you want
to sort an array in ascending order what
you need to do is use this sort function
so it will sort this array in ascending
order now if you want to sort it in
descending order use R sort that is
reverse sort similarly suppose you want
to sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this so in terms
of value what in terms of value means is
suppose in a given error there are keys
and values so it will sort the array
based on the values that is this 22 27
and 37 so the error will be the same him
since the values are already sorted now
if you want to sort the array in
according to key that is this you can
use case or that is key sort function
that is provided in PHP so in case of
key sort what it does is it will sort
the array in key that is the first one
would be D that is Duke second M Mac and
the third r that is raw now if you want
to sort this array in descending order
in terms of value you use instead of a
sort you use a reverse sort similarly if
you want to sort an array in terms of
key in descending you use K instead of K
sort k r sort that is K reverse sort so
these are the different sorting
functions that are in build into PHP
moving on
what will be the output of the following
code now if this code is given let me
give you some time and try to pause this
video and think of what will be the
output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1. how did it
happen but before that if you got it
correct congratulations
but if you want to understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference now we make changes in the B
variable with 2 followed by this
variable again which is calling the
value of a by reference so if we make
changes here we also make changes in the
value of a now if we display this since
the value of a is already changed by
reference it will display 2 1 that is
the value here and again since the value
of B is already 2 1 it will again
display it to 1. moving on what a
construct function and destruct function
in PHP so a Constructor or construct
function is automatically invoked when a
new object of a class is created and
then can be used to initialize value in
class so when you create a object an
object for a class A Constructor
function is automatically invoked but
this can also be so it does not contain
any value when it is invoked but you can
also use this construct function to
initialize some properties to give some
properties to the class which will act
as its default properties if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a distract now a destruct is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is distracted suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources next
is how can PHP and JavaScript interact
now PHP and JavaScript can not directly
interact with each other since PHP is a
server-side scripting language while
JavaScript is a client-side language but
there is a way that these two wonderful
languages can interact with each other
so we can swap variables since PHP can
produce JavaScript code to be
implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce JavaScript code from PHP
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to PHP via
a URL next question is explain type
hinting in PHP now in PHP type hinting
is used to specify the expected data
type that is array object interface etc
for an argument in a function
declaration now during a function call
suppose if argument does not match the
expected data type the runtime will
display an error and pro that is a fatal
error and the program will then
terminate now in this code here what we
are doing is we are type hinting so this
is this code is for string type hinting
and this code is for integer type ending
now if these particular set of functions
that have already specified the type
they are expecting does not receive the
same type of variable inside them the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate so moving on to our
final question of this video write a
class so yes this is a an assignment a
kind of assignment for you guys so what
you need to do is you need to write a
class to solve the following question
which I'm going to say so Implement a
class named basketball we all like
basketball right so Implement a class
name basketball with an attribute named
baskets so you have to create an
attribute name baskets and initialize it
to 0 as the starting position and then
create a method names core now when the
score method is invoked the baskets must
increase by one so let's see the
solution now so this is how you create a
class that is basketball
now inside this class what we are going
to do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we're going to do is we will
be using construct function as we
discussed to initialize some default
properties for the class so this
construct function is used to initialize
this baskets variable to zero now
suppose we do not call this function
score which is increasing the number of
baskets the default value will be
displayed as 0 every time now suppose we
invoke this core function every time a
basket is code this will increase the
number of baskets by one so this is
pretty simple and this is how you create
a simple class which will perform the
following question so that's it guys for
the full course tutorial on PHP
programming I do hope you have liked it
if you did do hit the like button and
subscribe to Simply learn for more such
content
thank you for watching stay tuned and
keep learning